So, da bin ich, ich war in letzter Zeit wirklich ziemlich oft on, ne? Ist euch das auch mal
aufgefallen? Ich denke mal schon. Zumindest, äh, eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen, dass,
man tatsächlich, wer hätte das gedacht? Absolut Massive High IQ Erkenntnis. Wenn man öfter
streamt, kriegt man mehr Abos, äh, mehr Subs auf Twitch. Wer hätte das gedacht? Also,
ne? Wer hätte das so ahnen können? Wer hätte das so ahnen können? Massive Sixhead Erkenntnis.
Easykiller, aiya, aiya. Aber sowas von. Und ihr werdet nicht drauf kommen, mit wem, doch
kommt ihr, weil ich hab's auf Twitter geschrieben, wie ich kacklobe, oder? Äh, mit wem ich gestern
Abend eineinhalb Stunden telefoniert hab. Kündigung schon raus. Bevor ich die Kündigung
losschicke, stelle ich mir Anschluss bei der Telekom. Es sei denn, ähm, es sei denn,
ähm, die Kündigungsfrist wäre sonst irgendwie zu kurz wegen, wegen zwei Jahreslaufzeit
und sowas. Ich hab nämlich gestern wirklich ernsthaft eineinhalb Stunden mit dem Doktor
Kaboom telefoniert. Und wir haben uns erstaunlich wenig die Zeit schon so ein bisschen über
Spiele unterhalten, so über eigentlich irgendwelche aktuellen Ereignisse, alles Mögliche, ja.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht hab, irgendwie merkt man, dass wir keine, keine 25 mehr sind.
Aber nicht, dass du trotz, äh, natürlich noch genauso viel Blödsinn erzählst wie
sonst, ja. Aber trotzdem, ja. Und mir ist eine Sache aufgefallen, richtig, richtig, richtig,
richtig Boomer, ja. Oder wie einer, wie einer auf Twitter geschrieben hat, Kaboomer. Ich
weiß, das tut weh. Leute, ich hab übrigens, ich hab übrigens was Neues. Ich hab, ich
hab was Neues eingefügt. Ich dachte mir, ich dachte mir, das findet ihr auch alle lustig.
Passt mal auf. Passt mal auf.
Guck, da unten ist ein Knopf hier.
Kann man natürlich passend dazu machen, ja. Man kann es aber natürlich, nachdem ja Bilder,
nachdem ich das ja in weiser Voraussicht so gemacht hab, dass Bilder unabhängig von
Sounds sind, kann ich auch irgendwas anderes anzeigen. Also man könnte, man könnte sogar
so weit gehen und den Wendler anzeigen, ja. Und dabei könnte man machen, was aber ziemlich
sinnlos ist. Ahi, ahi. Oder man könnte auch Gajibassen. Alles, alles möglich, ja. Ich
muss sagen, für das, mit wie heißer Nadel das Ganze hier gestrickt ist, funktioniert
das doch erstaunlich gut, ne. Macht Woda von wieder mit? Ja, bis jetzt schon, aber ich
würde nicht davon ausgehen, dass das die ganze Zeit so bleibt. Und ich finde das viel besser
als jedes Elgato Stream Deck oder anderes Zeug, ja. Vor allem, weil man es selbst gemacht
hat, ist es natürlich noch viel nicer. Richtige Hacker-Mans am Start gewesen. Ne, geht gepusht,
wird das nicht? Zumindest nicht in diesem Zustand. Hast du auch so eine tolle Performance mit
Woda von, wenn's geht, dann geht's. Das ist eigentlich ganz okay, aber meistens geht's
halt nicht. Musst du dann auch immer raustampen oder mit Hotkeys? Äh, was meinste? Andi Techgear?
Da ist mein Brain grad zu lau, ich hab's nicht kapiert. Musst, du meinst hier aus den, aus
den Emotes oder aus der VM? Oder aus der VM? Wie wär's, wenn du das Memetool... Ich glaube,
das ist was, womit man zumindest ein bisschen Kohle verdienen könnte, wenn man's ordentlich
macht, ja. Verkauf das an Elgato, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das... Wenn schon, wenn schon,
ich würd sowas gar nicht mehr verkaufen heutzutage, wenn schon wird das... As a Service angeboten,
in Azure, in der Cloud. Memetool As a Service. Äh, ach so, ne, muss ich nicht. Es kommt
ein bisschen auf das Game an. Also Andi Techgear, es kommt ein bisschen auf das Game an, und
zwar, wie das gemacht ist, so das Bild, das ist ein transparentes Fenster, das ist ja
kein Hexenwerk, ich mein, unter Windows müssen es halt nur mal Fenster sein, ja. Das sind
transparente Fenster, allerdings sind das ziemlich advance transparente Fenster, du
siehst, dass, ne, also du kannst hier durchklicken, ist überhaupt kein Problem. Das hat überhaupt
keinen Einfluss auf das, was dahinter liegt, das merkt eigentlich gar nicht, dass das Fenster
auf ist. Das heißt, du hast in Spielen eigentlich auch keine Probleme, sofern die Spiele im
Window-Modus laufen oder Borderless-Window, was so gut wie alle Spiele machen, die in
letzter Zeit rausgekommen sind, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel, und das Einzige, wo
es naturgemäß nicht funktionieren kann, sind exklusive Fullscreen-Anwendungen, weil
dann läuft das ganze Window-Manager-Zeug ja nicht, was drüber malen kann. Mach ein
UWP-App raus, eben lebe nicht. Ich werde niemals eine UWP-App machen, für nichts. UWP ist
so ein Kack. Und Microsoft hat da so gute Sachen drin, aber das Handling für Entwickler
ist mit UWP so dermaßen beschissen, wo ich mich echt frage, was, das denke ich mir dazu,
Microsoft hier. 100 Mal in Folge abgespielt. Microsoft ist so bescheuert, in UWP sind richtig
gute Sachen drin, beispielsweise das ganze UIL-Zeug ist für Windows-Verhältnisse ziemlich
gut, und auch viele andere Sachen, die sind gar nicht so doof. Das, was UWP komplett zerstört,
warum man als normaler Programmierer gar nicht erst auf die Idee kommt, eine UWP-Anwendung
zu machen, ist, UWP musst du, dass du den Kram vertreiben kannst, entweder du hast zwei
Varianten, entweder machst du es über den Windows-Store. Windows-Store ist für Nasch.
Keiner mag den Windows-Store verwenden. Ich will bei mir auf GitHub einfach eine aktuelle
Version anbieten können, Leute können sich runterladen, ausführen, gut ist. Die zweite
Variante ist, du kannst das sideloaden, beziehungsweise du kannst es auch über den Installer installieren,
dass das funktioniert, also UWP, MSIX nennt sich das Ganze, das ist quasi, das kann man
sideloaden, da muss man das nicht über den Windows-Store machen. Das Problem dabei ist,
und wahrscheinlich, also hoffe ich mal, dass jetzt manchen jetzt auch klar wird, warum
es so wenige UWP-Apps gibt und die paar, die es gibt über den Windows-Store, man kann
UWP-Apps hier normal vertreiben, so Setup Excel-mäßig, das Problem ist nur, man braucht ein gültiges
Code-Signing-Zertifikat und ich glaube, da gehen die Sachen so ab 300 Dollar im Jahr
los. Lass doch mal gucken, was kostet es denn? Code-Signing-Zertifikat, Free, Free schon
mal gar nicht, Free wirst du das schon mal gar nicht kriegen. So, was ist denn das günstigste
Angebot für ein Code-Signing-Zertifikat? Was ist denn das günstigste? Zeig mal her.
Cheap, komm mal, cheep, suchen wir mal. Cheapest, cheepest, gucken wir mal. Top, cheap, Code-Signing-Certifikat.
Also, was haben wir denn hier schönes zu bieten? Komodo, dass dieser Kackladen überhaupt noch
in Business ist, kann ich nicht verstehen. Also, Code-Signing. Was haben wir denn hier?
So, Komodo. Kann ich da draufklicken? Das wirkt irgendwie nicht sonderlich. Guck mal mal
bei Komodo, die haben einen scheiß Ruf. Mittlerweile vielleicht sind sie deswegen billig. Code-Signing-Certifikat.
Was kosten da sowas? Free, Free ist absolut pepega. So, schauen wir mal, was kostet so
ein Code-Signing-Zertifikat? Entweder nehmen wir das Code-Signing mit Minus oder das Code-Signing
mit ohne Minus. Was ist denn da besser? Ja, da wird es doch schon. So, ich glaube, man
braucht einen EV. Was ist denn ein EV-Code-Signing in dem Fall? Ich bilde mir einen, man braucht
für den... Ah nee, Extended Validation. Das brauchen wir nicht. Spaß denn. So, more
info. Ja gut, ich hab mit 300 im Jahr, ich hab mit 3... Was, Total? Wait a minute. Ach,
3 Jahre. Ah, yes. Ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist da los? So, aber man sieht schon,
also dieses Use-Save ist ja überall immer übelster, übelster Gebate. Warum haben die
so eine scheiß Url? Ja, weil es Komodo ist. Jetzt ist die Url nur die gleiche. Also wahrscheinlich
kommt da noch ein bisschen was dabei. Runden wir... Sind wir mal großzügig? Runden wir
sogar mal. Bleiben wir mal bei 85 Dollar. Muss man gar nichts runden, großartig. Das
heißt, du musst mindestens 85 Dollar, und da kommt wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
was dabei, im Jahr dafür bezahlen, dass du überhaupt eine UWP-App entwickeln darfst
im Endeffekt, die nicht über den Windows-Store vertrieben wird. Und ganz ehrlich, das macht
kein Entwickler einfach mal so auf spassende Freude. Zumal man das dann wahrscheinlich
auch schon wieder nicht für an... Vielleicht, vielleicht, wenn man noch Mobile-Store-Apps
macht, wo man auch sowas braucht, vielleicht, wenn man sowas schon hat. Aber das schränkt
den Benutzerkreis unglaublich ein. Deswegen, und ich hab's schon oft genug erzählt, deswegen
freue ich mich wirklich sehr da drauf. Aber die kommen ja nicht bei damit. Das fliegt
total unter dem Radar, und ich hab das Gefühl, das haben viele Entwickler gar nicht auf dem
Schirm. UWP stirbt, aber was stirbt, ist der Windows, nein doch, der Windows-Store stirbt
teilweise, und UWP als Plattform stirbt auch. Ich meine, es gibt ja nichts mehr. Es bleibt
ja von der ursprünglichen Geschichte, bleibt, was bleibt übrig? Die ganzen Smartphones
fällen raus, bleibt übrig Surface-Tablets, Surface-Hub-Geräte, eine Xbox, vielleicht,
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so sicher, wie das da mit UWP ist, ohne ein Windows-Desktop.
WinUI gibt's ja nicht für sich ab, doch, doch, klar. WinUI ist das, was in UWP das
UI macht. Allerdings, äh, qual kann ich gleich was zu sagen, was es da Gutes gibt, oder
ne, das willst du gar nicht wissen. Also ich betreibe da mein AirMix 300 über mein Audio-Interface.
Ähm, so, und, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau, das ist jetzt das schon, was UWP-Apps
macht, allerdings Microsoft ist auf die Big-Brain-Idee gekommen und hat gesagt, Jungs, UWP verwendet
ich keine Sau. Ähm, wir bringen jetzt mal Version 3 raus, irgendwann, dieses Jahr, und
Version 3, ähm, Version 3 unterstützt normale Windows 32, stinknormale, native Windows-Apps,
das heißt, endlich, nach wieviel, 5 Jahren, ähm, kann man jetzt ordentliche, moderne Windows-Uis
unter Windows mit einer Lösung von Microsoft, ähm, wieder benutzen. Ich mein, es ist,
es ist absolut lächerlich gewesen, die, ähm, Entwicklung von GUI-Applikationen unter Windows
die letzten 15 Jahre. Total lächerlich. Als.NET rausgekommen ist, hatten die, äh, damals
ganz neu, ja, hatten sie unter Windows-Forms ihre alte Windows-Technologie gerappt für
.NET. So, und, äh, ein paar Jahre danach sind sie, weiß ich, wann kam 2008 oder so, WPF
Release Day 2006, da kamen sie mit WPF um die Ecke, und das war für die damalige Zeit
relativ, sag mal, relativ revolutionär, ja, so mit, mit Data-Binding und XML für, für
das UI und so. Das war schon ganz nice. Das Problem ist aber, dass irgendwann Microsoft
gesagt hat, scheiß drauf, wir haben jetzt eigentlich was ganz Gutes, aber anstatt das
weiterzuentwickeln, machen wir Kachel-Apps. Und seitdem Microsoft mit Kachel-Apps angefangen
hat, ist Windows-UI-mäßig die Plattform tot. Weil es nur noch alte Sachen gab, quasi Windows-Forms
und WPF, was mehr oder weniger beides nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wurde, und Kachel-Anwendung
keine Sau machen wollte. Und übrigens das gleiche Problem hatte wie, wie die anderen
Sachen auch, ja. Und seitdem ist Windows-UI-Anwendung tot. Was meint ihr denn? Warum alles
mittlerweile, guckt euch Steam an, guckt euch Origin an, guckt euch, was weiß ich, was,
was, was, ich hab jetzt den ganzen, ich hab jetzt relativ wenig installiert, ehm, Wishlist
Studio Code an. Guckt euch den Kamer an, warum ist das alles nicht native Windows-Teuch?
Weil Windows-UI scheiße ist. Guckt euch die Avira-Oberfläche an, guckt euch Vivaldi an,
guckt euch die Logitech, na doch, die Logitech Gaming-Softer, die ist so dermaßen hässlich,
das ist wahrscheinlich auch eine native Windows 32, Windows-Forms-Gedöns-Anwendung, ehm,
OBS, OBS ist auch keine native Windows-Anwendung, OBS ist ehm, ganz viel C und ehm, enqueued
ehm, UI-Layer obendrauf, es ist, es gibt, das ist das WPF for the future, ja, ja, nicht,
ja, nicht wirklich. So, und Microsoft hat das seit Kachel-Anwendung mit Windows 8 komplett
verschissen, keiner hat mehr, man muss sich das mal überlegen, die Hauptplattform von
Microsoft hatte oder hat immer noch kein ordentliches, bis, bis das mal rauskommt, kein ordentliches,
die Hauptplattform von Microsoft, hat von Microsoft kein offizielles Framework, um moderne
UIs von Microsoft auf der Microsoft-Plattform schon hinzuentwickeln, das ist total hängen
geblieben, also, warum die sich da so lange Zeit gelassen haben, leuchtet mir überhaupt
nicht ein, ehm, deswegen machen ja, gräbst man ja auch unter Windows mit so vielen Krücken
rum, und deswegen sehen auch Windows-Apps aus, als kommen sie aus drei verschiedenen
Jahrzehnten, es gibt die, es gibt die, oder sag mal aus vier, aus vier, es gibt die AllinWin32-Geschichten
und WinForms-Geschichten, dann gibt's WPF-Geschichten, dann gibt's ein paar UWP, UWP-Sachen, ehm,
und das Kachelzeug und, eh, fuck jetzt, eh, und dann hast du noch ein paar, die ein bisschen
Windows XP-Style sind, aber das sind meistens auch WPF- oder, oder.NET-Geschichten, eh,
oder, oder WinForms-Geschichten, also, eh, man muss sich das mal überlegen, dass Microsoft
seit wann kam Windows 10 raus, und es ist ja seit Windows 8 eigentlich schon, Windows
8 Release Date war, guck mal, es gibt seit acht Jahren keine ordentliche Plattform mehr,
um Desktop-Anwendungen zu entwickeln, das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
wie verkackt hat's Microsoft da eigentlich, acht Jahre, das ist doch, das ist doch der
Witz, ich mein, kein Wunder, dass es da nichts ordentliches gibt, also wenn, wenn schon Windows-only-Anwendungen,
ehm, aus einer Mischung aus Qt und Electron programmiert werden, dann weißt du Bescheid,
Origin zum Beispiel, hier EA, die EA-Geschichte, das ist eine Mischung aus Qt, Web-Engine,
Browser, und, und bisschen Qt C++-Overlay, ja, wenn man Web-Anwendungen nimmt für Cross-Platform,
ok, aber es gibt halt viele Sachen, die sind Windows-only, bei Spiele hast du das Problem
nicht, Spiele brauchen im Prinzip nur ein Fenster und machen da drin dann eh was sie
wollen, aber so normale UI-Anwendungen gibt es nichts, das ist der Wahnsinn, ist WPF dead
in 2020, ja, sie haben es jetzt ja geschafft, dass.NET 5 endlich mal wirklich alles unterstützen
soll, von Windows Forms bis WPF bis, ehm, dann vielleicht WinUI 3, wir müssen mal gucken,
ob die ne Roadmap haben, wann da was rauskommt, und das, das fliegt voll unter dem Radar,
das haben viele, viele gar nicht aufm Schirm, weil es keiner mehr von Microsoft erwartet,
weil dieses unscheinbare Ding, was die hier auf GitHub haben, ja, mit Version 3, das wird
das erste, wenn sie es nicht verkacken, wohlgemacht, Apple hat das besser gemacht, ja, Apple, es
hat, es hat fast jeder besser gemacht, als, als Microsoft, ich mein, 8 Jahre lang kein
ordentliches UI-Framework für seine Hauptplattform anbieten, ist halt schon ein bisschen ehm,
massive, massive, eh, pepega, um nicht zu sagen, ahi, pepega, ist das, so, und das
ist ein richtig großer Schritt, wenn es Microsoft nicht verkackt, das bedeutet nämlich, vielleicht
für Erklärungen für Leute, die nicht so drinnen sind, ich kann aktuell solche Sachen,
solche, solche, ja, Applikationen, so, die, so, die so eine wahre Augenweide sind, wie
der Windows-Taschenrechner, die kann ich, die kann ich aktuell nicht programmieren
unter Windows, es sei denn, ich mach ne UWP-App draus, geht nicht, der Windows-Taschenrechner
ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein ziemlich doofes Beispiel, weil der sieht pothässlich aus,
aber die UI-Technologie unten drunter ist gar nicht schlecht, das, also ernsthaft, die
UI-Technologie unten drunter ist echt nicht übel, der Taschenrechner, ich weiß nicht,
ob der in der Praktikanten der Mittagspause das UI gemacht hat, aber die Technologie
unten drunter ist nicht schlecht, sieht man zum Beispiel auch schon daran, ihr seht, der
Hintergrund ist sowohl transparent als auch geblurred, das merkt man normalerweise nicht,
weil da achtet ja keiner drauf, ja, also da sieht man, da steckt schon ein bisschen was
dahinter, ihr seht es auch, dass man die Icons im Hintergrund sieht und so was, sprich, die
haben dann gewisse Logik, dass der Kontrast immer stimmt und so was, das ist gar nicht
dumm, das Problem ist, dass es halt kaum gescheite, kaum gescheite Apps gibt und das liegt daran,
weil halt UWP-Pflicht ist, ich frag mich gerade, ob mir vielleicht noch irgendwas ans Bein,
ja, das da zum Beispiel ist auch eine UWP-App und die sackt halt auch, aber hier erkennt
man schon mal, dass man ein ordentliches UI machen kann, wenn man dann will, wobei ich
mir gar nicht mal so sicher bin, ob das wirklich native ist oder auch irgendwie, das ist wahrscheinlich
auch irgendein Browser unten drunter, das passt jetzt nicht so gut, aber ich glaube,
es ist klar, worauf ich raus wollte, Microsoft hat es mal wieder geschafft, hoffentlich dann,
naja, ja, und wenn das mal rauskommt, bin ich gespannt, weil zum ersten Mal, genau,
weil ich sagen wollte, für alle, die nicht so in der Sache drin sind, damit kann man
zum ersten Mal wieder moderne Windows-Anwendungen entwickeln, die halt auch sich modern anfühlen,
die zum Beispiel Emojis darstellen können, die ganzen alten Dinger können das nicht,
kann das Notepad?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, kann das nicht, Notepad kann keine Emojis, weil Notepad ist wahrscheinlich
im Kern eine olle native Win32-Anwendung mit Winforms-Steuerelementen und sowas, kann das
nicht, da gucken wir uns was, also man kann relativ gut feststellen, was neue Anwendungen
sind, Windows und Punkt, kriegt man die Emoji-Tastatur, man kann relativ schnell feststellen, was
neue Anwendungen sind, wenn man einfach testet, ob Emoji-Input geht, weil man jetzt zum Beispiel
sagt, Datei öffnen und fügt einen Emoji ein und stellt fest, aha, der Input-Dialog
aus dem File-Explorer ist auch keine neue Windows-Anwendung, sondern was uraltes, das
ist der beste Test, den man machen kann für Windows-Anwendungen, so, zum Beispiel beim
Calculator, falls das Ding irgendein Feld hat, wo man Emojis einfügen kann, ich glaube ja
eher nicht, äh, nee, der würde das beispielsweise können, ähm, was haben wir da für eine Sache,
wo man, Visual Studio kann es übrigens auch nicht, ähm, ja wir können zum Beispiel mal
hier das Input, das Input-Feld vom Chrome nehmen, das kann das, aber ich bin mir relativ
sicher, dass, äh, die das nicht können, weil sie, äh, modernes Windows-UI-Framework verwenden,
sondern weil sie unter der Haube das Font-Rendering von Windows verwenden, was das kann, weil
die ganzen Browser machen ja sehr viel selbst, die verlassen sich ja zum größten Teil nicht
auf das, was auf der Plattform unten drunter da ist, richtiges PepegaOS, ja, Massive PepegaOS.
Es gibt irgendwo noch eine Windows-UI in Windows 10 von Windows 3.11, ja, wir haben ja auch
letztens was gefunden, das fand ich auch geil, guckt euch, guckt euch das mal an, an welches,
an welche Windows-Version erinnert euch dieses Fenster hier, also wenn das nicht Windows
2000 ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Das ist Windows 2000, oder? Das ist, der Kalender,
den Kalender probieren wir mal aus. Kalennn, den verwende ich nie. Go to Kalender. Ok,
der Kalender kann das, der Kalender kann das, das ist, das ist ein, hier sieht man es auch
schon im Hintergrund, das ist eindeutig eine neue, eine UWP, Fluent Design, was auch immer.
So, probieren wir mal, Eintrag hinzufügen, Event, siehst du, kann er, erkennt man es,
doch nicht, oder nicht Leute, nein, nein, nein, hu, hu, gerade noch mal Glück gehabt,
wurde von mehr, mehr, mehr, Vomegalul, DAF, OMEGALUL, NE, genau, so sieht es aus. So,
so viel, so viel zu Windows-Plattform, das heißt, man kann zum ersten Mal wirklich eine
ordentliche moderne Windows-Anwendung wieder basteln mit dem Kram, wenn die das hinkriegen,
so was richtig echtes, modernes, unter Windows, das passt nicht zusammen, ich weiß, aber man
muss sich mal, man muss sich überlegen, sowas wie Qt kann das unter Windows jetzt auch schon
seit ein paar Versionen, man muss sich, man muss sich, man muss sich mal vor Augen führen,
dass quasi Cross-Plattform-Tritt-Anbieter, UI-Limaries, mittlerweile besser dafür geeignet
sind, unter Windows, modernes, UI zu machen, als Windows Sachen selbst, also Microsoft,
um es unterm Strich zu sagen, Microsoft hat den richtigen PP-Gamout aktiviert gehabt die
letzten Monate, äh, die letzten Monate, die letzten Jahre und hat es verkackt. So, ich
hoffe, das wird, das wird mal wieder besser, weil an sich, muss ich, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
für reine Windows-Oberfläche finde ich, finde ich die ganze UI-Geschichte von Microsoft
gar nicht schlecht, ich bin kein, ich bin kein, kein, kein, äh, wie spricht man das eigentlich
aus, Samuel, Samuel, wie auch immer, ich bin kein Fan von ihrer, von ihrer komischen
XML-Interface-Markup, ist nicht so meins, ja, ähm, aber es ist okay, man, man, also
die QML-Geschichte von Qt gefällt mir besser und so blöds klingt, mittlerweile gefällt
mir auch HTML und CSS besser, aber es ist okay, da hast du die, du, du musst dir unter
Windows teilweise so die Beine ausreißen, um Dinge zu machen, es ist, es ist echt, es
ist echt lächerlich. Allein schon um, hier, diese Geschichte, ne, dass, dass ich GIFs,
GIFs overlayen kann, dafür musst du, musst du Riesenverrenkung machen, wenn du das ordentlich
effizient machen willst, dass diese, mein Overlay hier mit den GIFs ist extrem ineffizient,
ja, das ist ne, ne, ne WPF-Anwendung, weil WPF die einzige UI-Geschichte ist, die halbwegs
transparent unterstützt unter Windows, außer UVP, und UVP kann ich natürlich verwenden,
ähm, so, und, äh, PDF, äh, WPF, PDF, nee, nee, WPF, und das ist total ineffizient,
ich glaub, ich glaub, das Fenster hier, das Fenster hier mit Monk.js braucht glaub ich
500 MB RAM, ich weiß, es ist, es ist nicht so viel wie Elektron, ja, aber es ist, es
ist viel, guck, gucken wir mal, Prozess Explorer, Proc, Exp, schauen wir mal, was dieses eine
Fenster für RAM verbraucht, warte mal, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, kann man doch hier
sehen, oder? Äh, ach nee, Moment, wie heißt das Fenster überhaupt? Ähm, so gute Frage,
mal nach RAM, mal nach RAM sortieren, ja, hier, das ist es, glaub ich, BigBrain-Benahmung,
Web-Application 11, guck, man sieht gleich wieder Speicherbedarf runter geht, wenn Monk.js
verschwindet, wo sieht man hier das Fenster? Ich glaub, das ist nicht das Fenster, na doch,
müsste es sein, nee, aber wie gesagt, allein schon das Monk.js teilweise mehrere hunderte
MB verbraucht, oder auch hier, ganz schlimm sind solche GIFs, guckt euch das mal an, 650
MB für ein publisches GIF, oh, das geht ja noch weiter, wahrscheinlich Memory Leak das
auch noch, wenn ich das zu lange anzeige, guckt euch das mal an, Monka Memory Leak,
mit das 4K GIFs, ne ganz normale, ganz normale, so, und das ist halt mit WPF extrem ineffizient,
und wenn man das ordentlich machen will, hast du native unter Windows einfach nix ordentliches
dabei, das einzige, wie du es aktuell machen kannst, ist es komplett selber zu machen,
also sprich, du machst ein Fenster, nimmst beispielsweise FFmpeg zum Einlesen vom GIF
und renderst dann in das Fenster per, sei es OpenGL oder sei es DirectX, renderst du
quasi deine GIF-Frames rein, das funktioniert, ist ziemlich schnell, braucht kaum RAM, aber
das man, dass es kein native GIF, Bildelement aktuell unter Windows gibt, was halbwegs funktioniert,
ist halt auch schon wieder der Witz, ne, und unter UWP gibt's das, aber UWP kann man nicht
verwenden, ja, so viel zu Windows Zeug, was ich heute vor hab, ist eigentlich keine Videos
gucken, ja, oh mein Browser spackt rum, wat, nein, ich wollt kein Video abspielen, was
ich eigentlich machen wollte ist, hast du Kek im, ja hab ich hier, na Kek, den lachenden
hab ich nicht drinne, aber brauch ich ja nicht, ich hab den, das reicht, zumindest, was ich
heute vor hab, nix großartiges, und zwar, ich wollt mir mit euch mal ein bisschen überlegen,
ich hab ja ne Riesenliste, ich hab ja ne Riesenliste mit Sachen, die man mal im Stream machen
könnte, und ich wollte mal mit euch das besprechen, sprich, was man machen kann, ich bin ja letzter
Zeit relativ oft on, das heißt, ich brauch auch ein bisschen Programm, was man machen
kann, nein, ich bin kein Fulltime Streamer, ich hab das einfach nur in Titel geschrieben,
weil ich in letzter Zeit so oft on gewesen bin, RTX Voice, das ist ne gute Sache, das
können wir mal testen, allerdings ist das was, was man anmacht, feststellt, geht, und
dann macht man wieder aus, so, und natürlich finde ich auch gut, wenn auch der eine oder
andere ein paar Ideen hat, was man im Stream machen könnte, weil aktuell ist es so, wenn
ich mal nen Tag nicht gestreamt hab, dann denk ich mir schon so, ah nee, jetzt muss
der eigentlich nochmal online gehen, irgendwie hab ich grade so die, ja, so den Zug dazu
zu streamen, ich kann ja nicht immer online gehen und überhaupt nichts vorhaben, äh,
welches Audiointerface hab ich, ein MotoTrack 16, aber das einfach nur mit Headset anzuschließen
lohnt sich das nicht, das hat 16 Spuren und zig Inputs und sonst was, und kostet auch
mittlerweile ein bisschen weniger, aber immer noch zu viel, ja 400 Euro, äh, wenn du einfach
nur nen MMX300 anschließen willst, entweder an die Onboard Soundcard, die sind mittlerweile
ganz okay, ähm, oder was gerne in Audio formen und, und, äh, so bei Alarm, Alarm, es sieht
original aus, äh, das hier, die Dinger sind auch ganz gut, achso, das Mikrofon, es geht
ja nicht um das Audio, ähm, das Mikrofon habe ich an einem extra Gerät dran, und zwar
an so einem, allerdings würd ich nicht mehr den kaufen jetzt, das Mikrofon hab ich an
dem dran, weil das ein Input hat für 3,5mm Klinke mit Stromversorgung, was man braucht
für die Billig, in Anführungsgründen Billig Headset Mikros, ähm, ich könnte das auch
über das Audio Interface machen, da bräuchte ich aber einen Adapter für, dann mach ich
lieber da drüber, da hab ich auch mal einen zweiten, zweite Möglichkeit für mehr Inputs,
ähm, und was ich jetzt empfehlen würde, ist der hier, Yamaha, auch wie heißt das Ding,
A-G-Pult, A-G-6 ist das glaub ich, oh, die Lösung ist am Start, moin, ne, alles klar,
hab ich nichts gehört, Stufe 1 Subscriber, oh Massive, Massive IQ, die ganzen Subs hier
in letzter Zeit, der Chat ist eh schon hier auf, ähm, 500 IQ angewachsen, ja, Poggers
Bett, ähm, genau, also das, das Ding würde ich jetzt aktuell empfehlen, jo, bei mir ist
auch alles gut, ich bin in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen auf den Geschmack von, von Livestreams
gekommen, ich weiß auch nicht woran das liegt, also, ähm, ich hab hier den Twitch-Account
seit, frag mich nicht, drei Jahren oder so, wie findest du das, GoXLR, muss ich mal gucken,
seit drei Jahren, ich hab immer mal wieder gestreamt, aber ich muss sagen, so die letzten,
die letzten zwei, drei Monate, ist, keine Ahnung, hab ich so abends schon fast das schlechte
Gefühl, wenn ich nicht gestreamt hab, vielleicht, vielleicht kennste das, ja, aber ist irgendwie
ganz merkwürdig, wenn man erstmal richtig anfängt, ähm, ja, du hast selbst ja genug,
äh, genug da zu tun, ich mach ja auch hier komplett, äh, bescheuertes Zeug ohne YouTube-Bezug,
ja, deswegen bin ich trotzdem immer begeistert, dass da teilweise doch um die 200 Leute zu
gucken, wenn ich hier irgendwelche China-Geschichten einkaufe oder irgendwelche Sachen programmier,
ja, der Cryant läuft, ja, ich hab's gesehen, wo bist jetzt Tag 60, so in dem Dreh, ich
verfolge das immer so ein bisschen auf Twitter, so zeigt man hier GoXLR, wow, das Ding sieht,
das ist, das ist ein RGB-Mischpult, also, RGB-Beleuchtung macht vor nichts Halt, oder, ach Tag 6 und
2, wie komm ich denn auf 60? Keine Ahnung, geistige, geistige Umnachtung, äh, ich hab
immer noch das MMX300-Mikrofon, ich find's am angenehm, ich hab, ich hab noch ein paar
andere Dinger hier, ach 56, ja, dann, dann, dann, dann passt das ja so ungefähr, ähm,
ich hab ja noch von früher ein paar andere Mikros hier, ich hab nen, nen, nen, da, das,
das Ole Ploieti noch am Start, sogar noch im, im, im Schrank, nen Sennheiser, was ist
das, MK4 oder sowas, benutz ich alles nicht, ich verwende einfach mein stinknormales MMX300
mit ein bisschen Audio-Settings aus OBS. Früher German Taters, Alter, die Leute, was
denen wieder einfällt, bei German Taters muss ich immer an den Disstrack von Hartmann denken,
German Taters, gibt's das überhaupt noch? Genau. Oh Mann. Wenn man sich überlegt,
ne, über was für nen Bullshit man sich damals Gedanken gemacht hat, so richtig hängen geblieben
eigentlich, das ist, das, das ist, der Chat, der Chat hat recht, das ist, das ist tatsächlich
richtig, der Typ an sich scheint echt in Ordnung zu sein, ne, das letzte, was ich irgendwo
mal von dem gelesen hab, der hat nen ganz normalen Eindruck gemacht, ähm, ja, also
was sag ich zu dem Ding, ähm, kenn ich nicht, ist das so ne Mixer-Sampler-Voice-FX, ah,
das ist so ein Ding, wo man Stream-Effekte machen kann, da kann ich nix zu sagen, damit
kenn ich mich null aus. Magst du, du bist alt, ja, das ist mir gestern, das ist mir gestern
wieder aufgefallen, ne, wie gesagt, ich hab mir gestern seit, seit Jahren mal mit dem
Kabum wieder telefoniert, schon ewig her, und wir haben uns erstens verhältnismäßig
wenig über, über Games-Sachen unterhalten, über irgendwie alle möglichen anderen Sonst,
äh Sachen sonst, und irgendwie ist uns aufgefallen, dass wir echt schon ganz schön alt sind mittlerweile.
Und vor allem ne Sache, die mir immer auffällt ist, Kabuma, ne Sache, die mir immer auffällt
ist, dass mein Alter aufm Pass überhaupt nicht mit meinem Alter zusammenpasst, wie
ich das selbst so im Kopf irgendwie seh. Also total merkwürdig, wenn ich, wenn ich so nachdenke
so nach dem Motto, ja Max, wie alt bist du, dann, dann denk ich innerlich für mich so,
ja, keine Ahnung, so 24, 25 oder so, also irgendwie in dem Dreh, und dann stell ich
fest, ah ne, du wirst ja schon bald 36. WTF, richtig, Massive-Boomer. Habt ihr telefoniert,
wir haben, wir haben oldschool-mobile-phoned. Welche anderen 35-Jährigen benutzen Twitch-Emails
RL, ja das, das stimmt, das stimmt. Wahrscheinlich nicht so viele, außer Streamer, die 35 bin,
sind. Hab ich euch ja erzählt, wo der Azumi bei mir war, und er hat mir irgendwas, er
hat mir irgendwas auf seinem Notebook gezeigt, da kann er sagen, hier Max, guck mal, ich
bin fertig, oder kannst du mal gucken, irgendwas, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es war, und
da hab ich das Notebook von ihm genommen, hab das aufgeklappt und hab dann vor mich
hin irgendwie sowas gesagt in die Richtung wie, ah, yes, excellent, Fivehead. Und da
hab ich auch gedacht, ok, ich hoffe, er hat mir jetzt nicht so genau zugehört. Also, falls
ihr mal auf der Arbeit letztens bei jemanden gesessen habt, der ihr zufällig Azumi seid,
und der hat zu euch gesagt, ah, yes, excellent Fivehead, dann war ich das. Ich hab ja so
meine Bedenken, weil ich weiß, dass wir hier im Chat jemanden haben, der heißt Heinrich,
und so heißt der Azumi auch. Hab ich schon gedacht, oh nee. Nee, Enigma Code, ich hab
mittlerweile ein iPhone X, nee, X, fuck, was hab ich, XR, XR, 6S ist out. Hab ich noch,
aber verwende ich nicht mehr. XS hab ich. Wenn der Chat besser weiß, was man für ein
Telefon hat als man selbst, dann ist echt vorbei. So, genau, bevor wir uns die Sachen
angucken, die ich mir aufgeschrieben hab, was man streamtechnisch alles so machen könnte,
machen wir schon mal hier ein bisschen, mal schon mal Dokument auf, wo wir das dann nachher
reinschreiben können. Wie gesagt, falls ihr Ideen habt, was man noch im Stream machen
könnte, technikmäßig oder alles, was so im Großen und Ganzen mit den Sachen hier
zu tun hat, die wir halt machen, ja, sei es irgendwelche Sachen programmieren, irgendwelche
Technikgeschichten angucken, irgendwelche China-Sachen ausprobieren, was auch immer,
das Beste wäre, wenn ihr wirklich eine gute Idee habt, entweder schreibt den Chat mit
Antwooplos, sodass ihr es seht, oder wir haben im Discord einen Channel für Stream-Ideen,
da wäre ich euch sehr verbunden, wenn ihr eine gute Idee habt und das da reinschreibt.
Ich muss übrigens mal gucken, dass ich keine Subscribers übersehen hab. So, als letztes,
genau XSolution, wie gesagt, Dankeschön nochmal für den Sub, weiß nicht, ob ich schon
gesagt hab, schön, dass du mal reingeguckt hast, dann haben wir noch Half-Mal seit zwei
Monaten am Start und Easykiller, den hatten wir aber schon, den Easykiller hatten wir
schon, da kann ich mich dran erinnern. Schaut ihr mal den YouTube-Channel an, ich glaube,
der ist relativ kompetent. Ey, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt hier zum Channel-Rater irgendwie
werden soll, wenn dir die Videos gefallen, ist doch gut. So, ähm, wir brauchen mal einen
Cute-Emote, haben wir doch. So, Later, machen wir alles nicht, warum haben wir eigentlich
so viel Genöns auf? So, genau, ich wollte jetzt erst nochmal die Fragen aus dem letzten
Stream beantworten, das heißt, wir fangen jetzt mal von unten an. Was hältst du vom
Brave-Browser? Nix mehr verwende ich nicht mehr. Brave-Browser, ach, der macht Tutorials,
Programmieren und Allgemeinen über Technik. Ja, können wir uns, wenn du willst, können
wir uns mal irgendwas später mal angucken, aber es ist rar gesehen, dass es gute Technik-Videos
gibt in Deutschland. Ähm, was es in Deutschland gibt, ist, ähm, also es gibt viele Technik-Channels,
wo Technik dransteht, was auch als Technik irgendwo durchgeht, die sich halt mit Smartphones,
Tablets und sonstigen Geschichten beschäftigen. Das ist schon Technik, man kann jetzt nicht
sagen, dass das irgendwie Bisleading ist oder so, das ist schon Technik, ja, aber, für
mich nicht, ja, für mich ist Technik halt eher was in Richtung Programmieren, Elektronik,
irgendwelche Automatisierungsgeschichten, halt wirklich Technik und nicht, äh, was
kann das neue iPhone. Und da gibt's wenig Channels in Deutschland, hab ich zumindest
den Eindruck, die da guten Content vermitteln, man muss aber auch klar sagen, ähm, da gibt's
ja auch nicht so viele, die das sehen wollen, kommt ja auch dabei. Also, wenn sich jetzt
da, wer ist denn aktuell der größte Streamer? Ninja ist es definitiv nicht mehr, ich weiß
nicht, ob's, ob's, ob's Shroud da noch mit Mixer jetzt ganz gut, wer ist denn so der
größte Streamer? Sag mal, also, ich sag mal ein paar, die mir einfallen, die richtig groß
sind, ja. Nehmen wir mal, keine Ahnung, Deutschbereich, Montana Black, dann haben wir, genau, Anomaly
haben wir, XQC, Asmongold, Summit, also, die richtig großen Channels. Sowas wirst du natürlich
nie mit, äh, oder, auch wenn wir auf YouTube gucken, sowas wirst du natürlich nie mit
reinem Technik-Content in dem, äh, in dem Sinn erreichen, was ich unter Technik-Content
verstehe. Bei Linus Tech-Tips ist so ein Zwischending, Linus Tech-Tips macht das, macht das finde
ich ziemlich gut. Das hat zwar wenig Substanz für, ähm, ah ja, ich hab jetzt voll die
geilen technischen Sachen erfahren, so, das ist eigentlich bei Linus Tech-Tips Videos
nie der Fall, aber die sind insofern unterhaltsam, weil die halt schon teilweise so abgedreht
sind. So, nach dem Motto, worauf er den halben Handstand gemacht hat, dass die CPU überhaupt
gestartet ist und sowas, das ist schon cool. Ja, und es sind halt auch Sachen dabei, die
sind Schweine teuer, du machst nicht mal einfach daheim nebenbei irgendwie ein 32, äh, Kerne-Xeon-Bild
oder sowas. Deswegen ist das, ist das ganz cool. Und, ähm, sowas haben wir in Deutschland
auch nicht. So richtig Linus Tech-Tips gibt's in Deutschland nicht. Und ich sehe da schon
gewisses, gewisse, äh, hätte, das hätte schon, glaub ich, gewisses Potential auch
in Deutschland ganz gut zu funktionieren. Der Bauer. Ja, der Bauer ist aber andere Richtung.
Linus Tech-Tips ist ja sehr breit von, von dem, was, was, was der Inhalt mäßig ist.
Da kommt ja alles Mögliche. Von VPN bis zu Router-Tuning bis zu Rechner-Zusammenbauen
bis zu Monitor-Wand, da kommt ja alles Mögliche. Ähm, äh, der Bauer ist halt die, die Hardcore
Overclock und Hardware-Tests. Der Auer, ich sag immer der Auer. Weiß auch nicht warum,
ich weiß, dass es der Bauer ist. Ne, Alexi-Bexi kann ich mir überhaupt nicht geben. Allein,
nur wenn ich das Intro höre, dann muss ich weg. Das tut mir weh, das Intro. Das kann
ich mir nicht geben, das geht nicht. Ähm, der Knäherbär ist auch wieder da. Moin, ja,
ist halt schwierig. Wer soll das finanzieren am Anfang? Ja, gut. Ich meine ja mit damit
nicht, dass man gleich einsteigen sollte, ähm, wie Linus Tech-Tips mit der, mit der
Riesenproduktion. Das nicht. Aber man kann ja auch mit einem kleineren Budget Videos
sagen wir mal in diesem, in diesem, in diesem Spektrum bieten. Aber gibt es sowas wie Semper-Videos
auf Englisch? Klar, zuhauf. Wenn es die Sachen erklärt gibt's auf Englisch, gibt's das massig.
Zumal mich auch die, muss ich ehrlich sagen, letzten Semper-Videos hat mich alles nicht
großartig interessiert. So, also ich wollte ja noch ein paar Sachen beantworten. Und zwar,
ähm, was hältst du von Brave Browser? Nix mehr verwende ich nicht mehr. Ähm, hab ich
ne Weile verwendet. Ähm, aber ist für mich jetzt nicht mehr, nicht mehr wichtig. Was
ich aktuell verwende als Browser ist folgendes. Auf Android verwende ich den hier. Das ist
den Browser, den ich komplett, den ich unter Android verwende. Hast du das zu Brave nicht
gerade eben gesagt? Dann hab ich schon zweimal erzählt jetzt. Also verwende ich nicht mehr,
ist nicht meins. Hab ich mal ne Weile verwendet, aber mach ich nicht mehr. Ähm, das verwende
ich unter Android aktuell. Ist eigentlich ganz gut mit integriertem, das ist quasi ein
Custom-Chrome oder Custom-Chromium-Fork mit, äh, Adblocker und sowas alles drin. Das ist,
das ist ganz gut. Ähm, und äh, IOS, also sprich ganz normal auf einem Smartphone verwende
ich den eingebauten Safari und einen. Ähm, klingt mega shady das Ding, ich weiß. Private
Browser, oh wie heißt dieses Kackding, wartet mal kurz. Ich muss mal kurz drauf gucken.
Ich vergesse den Namen immer, weil er so einen ultrabeknackten Namen hat. Browser. Hä?
Wo ist er denn? Private heißt er einfach nur. Private Browser IOS. So. Hä, wie heißt
das Ding? Nee, das ist nicht der Porn-Browser. Du kannst das dafür verwenden, wenn du das
dafür verwenden willst, aber da gibt es andere Sachen. Nee, warum ich den, warte mal, ich
muss ja euch das mal kurz raussuchen, weil, ähm, der ist, der hat nämlich ein Feature
wofür ich ihn verwende und das ist konkurrenzlos gut. Ähm, Purchased Apps, ich sag euch gleich
wie das Ding heißt. Hier, so. Das klingt, wie gesagt, das klingt extrem, extrem, das
klingt extrem shady das Ding. Das wird, wird man sich normalerweise so, sowas, allein schon
mit dem Namen, wird man sich das normalerweise nicht installieren. Auch mit den Bildern hier,
das sieht wirklich, äh, ganz hardcore nach Scam und, und Monka Toss aus, ja. Das ganze
Ding. Aber, warum ich das, warum ich das, nein Videos, geht fort. Ähm, warum ich das
Ding verwende, ist, es ist der einzige Browser und es hört genau hin, weil das, äh, ist
wirklich was für die IOS Verwenden, Benutzer. Das ist der einzige Browser, den ich kenne,
unter IOS, der YouTube Videos im Hintergrund abspielen kann oder jegliche, jegliche Webvideos
im Hintergrund abspielen kann. Ich mein, ihr könnt euch natürlich auch, äh, YouTube
Red kaufen und, und Videos im Hintergrund abspielen. Geht natürlich auch, aber ihr
könnt einfach einen ordentlichen Browser verwenden. So, ich verwende den nur, um Videos
im Hintergrund abzuspielen. Das ist die einzige, der einzige Anwendungszweck für diesen Browser.
New Pipe auf Android Regel, das bringt, die aller, die Android Leute immer, weißt du,
vorher erzähl ich, was mir gut gefällt unter Android und jetzt sind wir grad bei IOS, dann
kommt da gleich einer an, ja, aber New Pipe auf Android, es ist absolut irrelevant für
Leute, die das iPhone verwenden. Das bringt denen gar nichts. Die können nicht einfach
aussagen, ich verwende mal New Pipe auf Android. Das geht nicht. So, und unter IOS ist das
die einzige Geschichte, die ich gefunden hab, die im Hintergrund YouTube Videos abspielen
kann. Man muss sich mal überlegen, im Jahr 2020 ist es ein Feature, ähm, dass man Videos
im Hintergrund abspielen kann. Also Audio, ja, schon, schon der Witz. Moin, äh, wie
ist, Moment, der Chat ging grad zu schnell durch. Wirst du wohl denken, was wirst du
wohl denken, das muss ich noch zeigen, ich denke allgemein recht wenig in letzter Zeit,
äh, dass die, dass die 300-, 3000er Serie von Nvidia wirklich so viel stärker sein
wird als die 2000er Serie. Ich hab mich damit null beschäftigt, aber ich denke insofern
schon, weil sie hatten ein bisschen das Problem, also ich hab mir gesagt, keine Ahnung, ich
hab mich null damit beschäftigt, ähm, ich denke insofern schon, die hatten ein bisschen
das Problem, ich hab eine 1080 Ti. Für mich gibt es aktuell keinen Grund, abzukraden
auf eine 2080 oder 2080 Ti. Das, was die 2080 Ti schneller ist, ist es preisleistungsmäßig.
Disclaimer, danke an Nvidia fürs zur Verfügung stellen und überlassen der 1080 Ti, ich hab
die ja nicht selbst bezahlt, aber wenn ich sie selbst bezahlt hätte und mir jetzt eine
2080 Ti kaufen möchte, würde ich nicht machen, ist einfach zu teuer für den 11-, 12-prozentigen
Geschwindigkeitsgewinn. Man könnte jetzt sagen, die 1080 Ti war einfach zu schnell.
Aber eigentlich sollte es so sein, es sollte zwischen Generation zu Generation, grade auch
im High-End-Segment sollte schon ein gewisser Boost drin sein. Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass der Mist 1000 Euro plus kostet. Was kostet ein 2080 Ti zurzeit? Ja, 1000. So und deswegen
könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es bei der 3000 wieder mal einen ordentlichen Boost
gehen wird. 25% ist okay. Das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein und Nvidia kann es ja auch machen,
weil Nvidia keine Konkurrenz hat, was Grafikkarten angeht. Hast du den 501 Kilogramm Deadlift
gesehen? Nee, ist eigentlich nicht so ein Thema, was mich großartig interessiert, aber
kann ich mir mal angucken. Deadlift. Ist das neue World Record? Oder Zugucker hat eine
technische Frage. Können wir uns gleich angucken. Ey, das ist der Dings, ist das der Game of
Thrones-Mann? Die Rolle, die irgendwie in Game of Thrones fünfmal unterschiedlich besetzt
war. Oder was geht? Der Kerl, ne, dem sein Bein ist so groß wie ich. Meint ihr, der gesamte
Chat würde das zusammen schaffen hier? Ich meine, wir haben 200 Leute im Chat. Chat, meint
ihr, wir schaffen das, wenn jeder zwei Kilo hebt? Wir passen da überhaupt nicht dran mit
200 Leuten. Wie soll das funktionieren? Mit Cute Power. Wieso rumschreien? Da bricht
der Untergrund gleich ein. Alter. ETR 500 Kilo. Ich weiß nicht, was ist, was ist, was
ist Welt Record? Aber heftig, ja. Eats war das, genau. Das ist jetzt der Welt Record,
aha. Okay. Also war der Welt Record wirklich bei 500 Kilo? Das ist so, so ein, eigentlich
ein viel zu glatter Punkt für, ähm, für den Welt Record. Welt Recorder sind meistens
ein Chat. Hm, okay. Ja, gut, wie auch, wie dem auch sei. Als nächstes erwarte ich Inscope
ein. Also, wo war ich denn jetzt dabei? Genau, wir wollten das, wir wollten das vom Zugucker
beantworten. Der hat irgendwie eine ziemlich lange Frage geschrieben. Genau, also der Zugucker
fragt, ähm, mal eine technische Frage. Ich bin eigentlich Webentwickler, aber hab durchaus
auch Erfahrung in anderen Sprachen. Ich muss jetzt mal wieder Recht der Sache Rechnung
tragen, dass ja die Aufmerksamkeit heute nicht so hoch ist, deswegen mach ich euch wieder
das Bewegung im Bildschirm ist, während ich das vorlese. Und hier den machen wir auch
noch an. Ähm, also ich bin eigentlich Webentwickler, aber hab durchaus auch Erfahrung in anderen
Sprachen. Drei Mal die Woche werden bei uns die Preise für Aktionen im Online-Shop geändert.
Welche Sprache eignet sich dafür am besten? Hat da jemand Erfahrung? Das Ganze wird über
eine Rest-AP realisiert. Per C-Sharp kann ich das Ganze schon händeln? Wäre das zeitgeschäumt
möglich? Sorry, vielen Dank. Äh, was genau willst du machen? Du willst über eine Rest-AP
Preise ändern im Online-Shop? Alter, der Knäherbär! Du willst über die Rest-AP Preise ändern
im Online-Shop? Ähm, ich glaube, das könnte man viel, viel einfacher machen als ein extra
C-Sharp Programm für zu basteln. Bist du noch da? Ist der Zugucker noch am Start?
Also, je nachdem, je nachdem, wo die Daten herkommen, ähm, wo ist, wo ist denn die Quelle?
Wo ist denn die Quelle? Also, man könnte nämlich ganz einfach, man könnte nämlich
ganz einfach sich jegliches Programmieren schenken, ähm, und, äh, einfach ein stinknormales
Curl Shellscript machen. Mal angenommen, du hast ein CSV, wo die Preise drinstehen,
dann wäre das relativ simples Shellscript, das zu machen. Wenn die, wenn die Aufrufe
einfach sind. Also, du könntest einfach eine Curl, Curl durchlaufen lassen, gut ist. Ähm,
wenn natürlich ein bisschen mehr Logik brauchst, vielleicht noch mit Datenbankanbindung oder
sowas, dann ist was mit.NET sicherlich nicht verkehrt. Das würde sich dann anbieten. Es
kommt ein bisschen auf die, auf die, äh, Architektur drum herum an. Also sprich, ähm,
wo kommen die Preise her? Ähm, ist das die gleiche Datenbank, die auch der Shop benutzt?
Ähm, ja, so ein bisschen was drum herum. Also, die einfachste Sache, die mir einfallen
würde, wäre einfach, äh, ein paar Curls, äh, untereinander, äh, in, in den Shellscript
packen und das nachts ausführen lassen. Ähm, ansonsten könnte man es natürlich auch mit
einem.NET Programm machen. Du kannst auch ohne Probleme in einem.NET Programm, ähm,
so, so eine Art Cron-Timer einbauen. Kein Ding, gibt sogar fertige, fertige Libraries
für, die das machen. Startest da einfach und da führt der dann alle, jeden Freitag
um 5 Uhr führt da irgendwas aus. Ist auch kein Ding. Ist halt die Frage, wo die Sachen
herkommen. Na, wenn du jetzt, wenn du die neuen Preise aus den Datenbank abfragen willst,
dann würde ich es nicht unbedingt per Shellscript machen, das ist eklig. Ähm, dann würde ich
es vielleicht wirklich in einem.NET Programm machen. Elektron-Plink-App, nee, nee, nee,
wenn schon Flutter, wenn schon Flutter-App. Flutter ist der heiße Shit zurzeit. Schau
sie mal an. 91.000 Sterne auf GitHub. Ja klar, also wenn du den Rest, gut, wenn du den Rest
abzuguckst, dann ist die Programmiersprache, die ist ja vollkommen wurscht eigentlich.
Na, das kannst du auch meinetwegen in PHP oder so machen oder in, oder, ich hoffe wir
bleiben davon verschont von Java. In Java kannst du in jeder x-beliebigen Programmrufe
von Ruby bis Paeisen bis sonst was kannst du, kannst du, eigentlich kannst du es ja überall
machen. Cobol. Ah, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. HTTP Post in Cobol? Geht sowas? Socket
Brokrumming in Cobol? Ok, anscheinend gibt es über irgendwelche Hex die Möglichkeit
sogar das in Cobol zu machen. Ja, Cobol. Ja, Go ist auch super dafür. Go ist eine ganz
tolle Geschichte dafür, weil Go kannst du das Binary einfach irgendwo hinschmeißen
und gut ist und es läuft. Go ist auch eine wunderbare Sache dafür. Wie gesagt, du kannst
das in jeder x-beliebigen Programmiersprache machen. Ja, so, Fragen beantworten. Wollten
wir eigentlich noch fertig machen. Ähm, was historisch seit Origins überhaupt, also
da ging es um Assassin's Creed. Äh, Assassin's Creed Odyssey im Stream. Ja, ich muss tatsächlich
sagen, ähm, ich hab's mir gestern gekauft. Was für einen Proger-Stream, was ist das?
Ne, das geht, das der Zuschauer, das kannst du auf jeden Fall machen, ist in jeder x-beliebigen
Programmiersprache. Äh, Moment, der Darkreader spack da grad ein bisschen rum. Ähm, Moment,
was? I'm tracking my cat's location. Ah, excellent. Da freut sich die Katz. Ähm, ok,
er tracked seine Katze. Wie kann man denn am einfachen sich eine neue Adresse vom Router
geben lassen unter Windows? Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht unter
Windows. Echt nicht, keine Ahnung. Ähm, unter Linux kannst du neu anfordern. Es kommt ein
bisschen auf den, es kommt ein bisschen auf den Router an. Wenn du einfach nur dhcp neu
anforderst, wird dir der Router meistens die gleiche IP-Adresse geben. Musst mal gucken,
wie man force new IP dhcp kleint. Äh, genau, dhcp minus R. Dann sagt er nämlich bitte
release meine, mein lease. So, und das müsste man irgendwo unter Windows auch machen. Ich
weiß halt nicht, wie man das unter Windows macht. Du müsstest, es müsste da irgendeinen
Bucken, Kommandozeile, was auch immer geben, irgendwo in den Tiefen von Windows versteckt,
wie man das, wie man das machen kann. Windows renew IP force. TP-Link. Oh, guck mal hier,
big brain. Geben sie IP-Conflict, IP-Conflict, ja das ist, das ist unter Windows, kann das
durchaus sein, IP-Conflict slash release. Danach geben sie ein IP-Conflict slash renew,
big brain Google Skills. Und da muss ich wieder mal auf eine Sache zu sprechen kommen, die
ich auch den Azubis, wir haben ja nicht mehr so viele, aber die Idee, wir haben immer
sagen, man muss es nicht wissen, man muss nur gut danach suchen können. Das ist das Wichtigste.
Ach guck mal, der PC lustig, der Chat wusste das schon wieder vorher. Der Chat. Oh. Also,
was haben wir hier am Start? 360 No Scope. Ja, für den QoQ machen wir das auch nochmal.
Wo habe ich es denn? Wo habe ich mal 360 No Scope? Leute, wo ist es? Die Suche ist kaputt,
die Suche habe ich noch nicht wieder repariert. Wollen wir mal gucken, ob die Suche funktioniert?
Oh, die Suche ist kaputt, RIP. Die Suche ist kaputt, guckt. Es heißt nur No Scope, da
ist es doch. Max, kennst du Doom Crossing? Ja, kenne ich. Das ist das Animal Crossing
Musikvideo, das kenne ich. Wobei der richtige Emote dazu ist eigentlich das hier in Kombination
mit dem hier. Also, was macht der Typ hier mit seiner Katze? Y-Fest Lost Multiple Cats,
was machen die denn mit ihren Katzen? Das ist bestimmt Kokona. Das ist bestimmt Kokona-Land,
die irgendwie Sachen immer oftmals etwas, weiß nicht, unüberlegt vorgehen. Okay, ich
kann das aber übrigens verstehen, ja. Also sprich, wenn man schon mehrere Katzen die
die letzten Jahre über verloren hat, dass man da ein bisschen vorsichtig ist. Kann
er auch verstehen. Ich meine, im Prinzip ist es bei mir auch so. Ich hatte jetzt halt nur
alte Katzen und die haben es alle nicht so lange gemacht. Die erste hier, die kennt
ihr ja noch aus ein paar Videos, die hier. Die hatten wir eine Weile, die hatten wir
vom Nachbar, der hat das Haus ja verkauft. Danach hatte ich, Moment, wo ist sie? Die
tatsächlich Barbie hieß, muss man sich mal vorstellen. Ich hätte meine Katze im Leben
ja nicht Barbie genannt, sondern sie hieß halt so vom ursprünglichen Besitzer und da
hat die auch drauf gehört, aber Barbie ist so eine Katzenname. So, und jetzt habe ich
Chico. Chico ist Chico, ist gar nicht hier drin, das stelle ich gerade fest. Chico ist
nur hier. Chico ist nur hier, Chica, Chico, wie auch immer, ist nur hier. So, mir fällt
gerade mal ein, ich bin meiner Zeit voraus, was das angeht. Ich meine, meine Katzen sind
äußerst divers, muss man mal sagen. Guck mal hier, eine graue Gestreifte, eine schwarz-weiße
und jetzt eine bunte. Also, da kann mir, da kann mir keiner was vorwerfen hier. Die nächste
wird dann grün, ich hoffe, dass ich lange keine nächste mehr brauche. Okay, also, was
macht ihr? Er trägt seine Katzen. Tracker-Pixel? Was ist denn ein Tracker-Pixel? Ah, so ein
Plutus-Ding. Das ist, sowas habe ich doch auch hier. Sowas habe ich doch auch hier am
Start. So ein Ding, sowas habe ich hier auch. Habe ich an den Schlüssel dran, dass man
es findet, wenn man es mal verloren hat. Und die Kleinen könnte man dafür auch wunderbar
verwenden. Das ist was für ein Prograstream, ja, das stimmt. Also, 10 Euro Tracker-Pixel,
äh, ja, 10 Euro. Tracker-Pixel-Schwarz. Oh, oh, oh, zu Lull. Okay, erstmal Amazon
hier auch aus dem Dark-Rider-Neben, das sieht beschissen aus. Also, was macht er? Ich meine,
ich kann es mir vorstellen, da hängt der Katze, das Plutus-Ding um den Hals an den ESP32 und
checkt einfach die Signalstärke. Das wäre relativ easy. Und wenn man mehrere ESPs im
Haus verteilt hat, kann man an mehreren Stellen die Signalstärke checken und dort, wo die
Signalstärke am größten ist, ist die Katze halt. Allerdings würde ich das nicht machen.
Allerdings würde ich das nicht machen mit Katzen-Tracking, weil, ähm, ich habe zumindest
bei den Katzen die Erfahrung gemacht, die ich bisher hatte, die mögen alle keine Halsbänder
und ich glaube, die meisten Katzen mögen absolut keine Halsbänder, das ist ja kein
Hund oder so, die lassen es halt über sich ergehen, wenn sie halt da lange dran gewöhnt
sind, aber die meisten mögen es nicht und was Katzen absolut nicht abkönnen, ist Halsbänder
mit Glöckchen, dass es beim Laufen bimmelt, weil Katzen wollen vor sich hin stelzen,
die wollen vor sich hin schleichen und nicht Klingel, Klingel, Klingel überall anlaufen.
Was ich auch immer richtig zum Fremdschämen finde, gibt es ja auch jede Menge Videos
auf YouTube, wie man seine Katze badet. Man muss seine Katze nicht baden. Die erste Katze,
die ich hier hatte, die war den ganzen Tag mehr oder weniger draußen, außer halt, wenn
sie drin war, ich weiß, Massive, ähm, und die musste ich nicht einmal waschen, ja, also
der einzige Grunde Katz zu waschen ist, wenn er wirklich irgendwie irgendwo reingefallen
ist, reingefallen ist, Sachen, die halt so nicht wieder abgehen richtig, ähm, du musst
deine Katze eigentlich nicht, nicht waschen, ja. Naja, ähm, verstehe ich nicht, warum es
da so viele Videos zu gibt. So, also was macht er denn hier, 10 Euro Tracker, äh, zwei ESP-2
in 3 Sports, wir hatten das nur gedacht, das ist genau das, wie ich es auch gemacht hätte,
like these ones, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine NodeMCU, stand da, ja, sowas in der Richtung,
genau, ähm, er hat einen Controller im Wohnzimmer und eine andere im Schlafzimmer, ähm, also
quasi auf jedem Stockwerk, 3D-Case gibt es jede Menge, ach, haben die jetzt, haben die
irgendwie den eigenen, den eigenen Marketplace oder so, oder die Seite kenne ich gar nicht,
ich kenne bloß Singiverse für 3D-Drucke, was ist denn das, ich kenne den nur als Hersteller
vom 3D-Drucke, oh ist ja cool, ist das eine Alternative zu Singiverse, taugt das, weil
da sind wenige, wenige Votes und sowas, wollen wir mal speichern, suchen, fertigge-sliced-code,
das ist ja auch nicht schlecht, ok, dann suchen wir mal nach einem D1-Mini, ob es da, ok,
oh, finde ich cool, oh nice, guck mal, der hat sogar schon eingebaut, die, ähm, den Stromanschuss,
das finde ich cool, gefällt mir, das Gehäuse, das gefällt mir echt gut, kann ich, kann
ich mal brauchen, suchen wir mal nach, ähm, mit OLED, OLED-Gehäuse, ja, ok, die Seite
finde ich, die kannte ich gar nicht, wie gesagt, ja, über Singiverse verwenden und Singiverse
ist halt wirklich langsam, hat grad schon einer im Chat geschrieben, sortiere vielleicht nicht
nach neueste, wo sortiert man überhaupt, wo sortiert man hier überhaupt, das finde ich
ja noch mal doof, dass man nicht sortieren kann, nach Bewertung, oder nach neueste, oder
sonst was, aber ich werde es mir mal merken, ok, alter, hat zwei dieser Boards, so eine
ganz normale ESP-Developer-Boards, pro Stockwerk, ESP-Home kann man sich schenken, kann man
ohne Probleme selbst programmieren, oder ein Tablet, ok, das ist relativ simpel, die Lösung,
aber die funktioniert, die funktioniert, die funktioniert definitiv, das habe ich selbst
schon gemacht, also Bluetooth, Low-Energy-Bluetooth-Signalstärke ausgelesen im ESP32, das ist easy, also die
Lösung ist simpel, aber die Lösung wird funktionieren, Songname, Playlists, ja, eine Stunde 27 aus
der Epic Chillstep Collection 2019, Massive, ja, wir beantworten gleich noch ein paar Fragen
weiter, ich wollte euch bloß noch mal gerade was, kein Sellout-Modus, ja, auch wenn wir
hier auf Twitch sind, was fragen, ich habe jetzt angefangen auf Amazon hier, und ich
bin fast durch mit der Serie, hier ist das Upload, hat das jemand von euch schon geguckt,
also ich bin jetzt bei Folge 6 oder so, ist jetzt neu, gibt es das seit ein paar Tagen,
ich fand das eigentlich ganz nett, ich fand das eigentlich ganz nett, ein bisschen, ein
bisschen, ein bisschen viel, ein bisschen viel Herzschmerz zwischendurch, ja, also letztendlich
geht es darum, dass sie ziemlich dem aktuellen Zeitgeist entsprechende, eine Simulation kann
man es ja nicht nennen, eine ziemlich dem aktuellen Zeitgeist entsprechende Vision,
Utopie, wie auch immer man es nennen mag, haben wie man quasi ein Leben nach dem Tod
im Computer realisieren könnte, so mit Microtransactions und Pay2Win und solche Geschichten, das fand
ich eigentlich auch ganz cool, das fand ich, das fand ich ganz cool gemacht, na im Prinzip
geht es halt darum, dass irgendjemand stirbt und kommt halt in eine Computersimulation
rein und dann, den Rest müsst ihr euch selbst angucken, aber die Microtransactions haben
sie ganz gut gemacht, Pay2Win, wenn man tot ist, genau, wenn du Golf spielen willst, kostet
das Geld, wenn du irgendwie extra Frühstück haben willst, kostet das Geld, wenn im Zweifel
wirst du sogar eingefroren für einen halben Monat, ja, es ist eigentlich ganz nett gemacht,
wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt bei Folge 6, es ist ein bisschen, es könnte ein bisschen
mehr Story und ein bisschen weniger Love Story sein, ja, weil es ist ziemlich, also wer gar
nichts übrig hat, wenn es dann quasi nur Action geben muss und wenig, wenig Herzschmerz
drum herum ist das nichts, also das ist schon eine ganz gute Unterhaltungs-Serie, aber
sagen wir mal so, die ganze Love Story nimmt vielleicht ein bisschen zu großen Platz ein,
aber ich kann es bis jetzt empfehlen, ich fand es echt nice, mal ein bisschen was anderes,
ein bisschen was anderes vom Ansatz her, wovon ich echt enttäuscht war, muss ich jetzt mal
sagen, ich habe mir ja eine Netflix-Probe-Abo geholt, ich hatte davor, ich bin der Letzte,
ich bin halt, wie gesagt, Hyperboomer 1984 geboren, ich hatte noch nie eine Netflix-Abo
vorher und ich hatte mir als die Witcher-Serie rausgekommen, jetzt habe ich mir gesagt,
scheiß drauf, machst du mal ein Probe-Abo, ein Probe-Monat bei Netflix, ich habe es auch
direkt wieder gekündigt, also quasi angemeldet und gekündigt und dann habe ich mir den Switcher
angeguckt auf Netflix, über die Serie habe ich mir schon ein paar Mal ausgelassen, war
ganz okay, übermäßig begeistert und habe ich ein bisschen umgeguckt, ich muss sagen,
viele der Netflix-Produktionen haben mich nicht angesprochen, aber viele der Netflix-Produktionen
haben mich irgendwie nicht angesprochen, ich will nicht sagen, dass es bei Amazon so viel
anders ist, den meisten Amazon-Kram gucke ich ja auch nicht, ich habe halt Prime, weil
ich Prime schon ewig habe, jetzt nicht explizit für Videos, also das ist bei beiden ähnlich,
aber ich würde mir jetzt nicht ein extra Abo holen dafür und was mich halt auch abgeschreckt
hat bei Netflix, ich habe ein paar Filme, habe ich ein paar Sachen mir rausgesucht und
auch ein paar Serien und da habe ich Reviews gelesen und die Reviews waren alle sehr verhalten
und fast durchgängig so, dass man gesagt hat, ja gute Idee, gute Ansätze, aber Umsetzung
nur halbherzig und das ist fast das gleiche, was ich auch hätte über die Witcher-Serie
können, gute Ansätze mit Sicherheit, ganz gute Vorlage, aber irgendwie weit von dem
entfernt, was man nicht draus machen können.
Geissi sagt, zwei Drittel der Netflix-Eigeproduktionen sind Müll, ist schwer rauszufinden, was gut
ist, aber manchmal ist es echt Gold, ja, ist es selten alles Schrott, das stimmt, ja,
kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass da auch was gutes dabei ist.
Ja, hat mich, wie gesagt, nicht überzeugt, ich habe dann auch nicht weiter Abo verlängert.
Vodafone macht es, echt, nö, geht doch, kein Vodafone-Problem, man weiß aber nie, könnte
jederzeit soweit sein, Leute, MonkaS, es könnte, oh doch, Vodafone, oh, Vodafone macht Probleme,
jetzt gerade, ich hab's gesehen, es hat geleckt, Vodafone macht Probleme, oh nee, nee, es geht
los, Leute, es geht los, es geht los, Vodafone, please, okay, es scheint sich stabilisiert
zu haben, gut, dann hoffen wir mal, dass es so bleibt, äh, nee, nee, den VPN hab ich
gerade nicht an, okay, also, wo ist der Kambum, häh, Kündigung schon raus, hab ich schon
beantwortet, wann musstest du heute das letzte Mal kecken, keckte, ich kecke doch die ganze
Zeit.
Äh, wie würdest du am besten den Einstieg in Linux angehen, würde mich gerne ein bisschen
in das Thema Linux-Schelle anarbeiten, habe mir zum Gaming-PC ein Laptop, doch klar hab
ich das schon beantwortet, ich hab gesagt, am besten ist, wenn du schon einen richtig
niceen Gaming-PC hast, am besten installierst du den Linux-LMVM und probierst da ein bisschen
rum, dann hast du viele Probleme nicht, das haben wir uns gerade angeguckt, äh, QO-Notes,
das hatte ich auch schon beantwortet, hast du mal den neuen Edge getestet, ja, wir haben
ihn sogar noch hier installiert irgendwo, ne, da, ist der neue Edge, sogar mit Adblock
schon dabei, wo ich halt nicht verstanden hab, warum ich den verwenden soll, Brave hatten
wir schon, oder vorne, oh, was haben wir hier für eine Frage, hey Max, ich möchte mein
Netzwerk auf 10G umstellen, die Geräte wie Switch, Netzwerkkarte habe ich alles rausgesucht,
die Frage ist, ob das mit einem RAID 10 HDD funktioniert oder nicht, klar, funktioniert,
funktioniert, ähm, ich mein, 10 Gigabit voll kriegen wirst du damit wahrscheinlich
nicht, aber trotzdem, wobei, du, also mit 10 Festplatten, lesen, schaffst du das?
Ja, RAID 10, doch klar, was gemeint ist, doch, das wird als 1-0, wahrscheinlich, ich glaube,
es wird sogar 1 plus 0, wenn man ganz korrekt ist, aber scheiß doch drauf, ähm, also,
ja, das funktioniert, ähm, und mit 10 Festplatten, lesend, kriegst du auch ein 10 Gigabit Netzwerk
halbwegs ausgelastet, lesend wohlgemerkt, ah ne, Moment, nicht 10 Festplatten in RAID
10, äh, ne, dazu müssen gar keine 10 Festplatten sein, dazu müssen es, glaube ich, nur 4,
oder?
Chat, wo ist die Ausbildung, bei wem ist die Ausbildung, nicht so lange her, wie viel Platten
gibt es mindestens für ein RAID, äh, für ein RAID 10, 4 Stück, ne?
4, ah, Chat, Chat kennt sich aus, Chats, Chats, die high IQ Hackermans am Start, ähm, damit
wirst du das nicht hinkriegen, aber ein RAID 10 rein mit 4 Festplatten macht wahrscheinlich
auch keiner, also wenn du da ein bisschen mehr hast, ähm, dann kriegst du das ganz gut,
ähm, ausgelastet, denke ich, so, und, ob es sich lohnt, kommt auf der Anwendungszweck
an, hast du dir schon mal better, better Twitch TV, was, better, better Twitch TV, was soll
denn das sein, noch besseres, noch besseres Twitch TV, oder was meinst du, hä, better,
better, better Twitch TV, was zum, was ist, oh, die Seite mach ich nicht auf, die Seite
mach ich nicht auf, wer weiß wo ich da rauskomme, ich hab keine Ahnung was das ist, better,
better Twitch TV, also, ist das dann, better, better Twitch TV, nein, kenn ich nicht, sagt
mir nichts, kein Schimmer, ha, gbaited, ähm, so eigentlich wollte ich ein paar Videoideen
noch jetzt durchgehen heute, wir sind schon wieder nur, nur aufs Schwätzen, aber dafür
ist Livestream letztendlich da, ja, ähm, Janik sagt, muss korrekt sein, der Janik 0.0.0.0.0,
um genau zu sein, excellent, ähm, mein Windows ist in den letzten 4-5 Tagen ein paar Mal
ohne Warnung runtergefahren, das liegt daran, dass du mir nicht dein Twitch Prime Sub dagelassen
hast, das ist eindeutig, ich hab das Problem fachmännisch analysiert und bin zu diesem
Schluss gekommen, also, ähm, jetzt bin ich vor zwei Tagen kurzerhand auf Linux Popo
S geswitcht, oh, da hast du aber mal ganz, ganz großen Sprung gemacht, überlege zur
Zeit auf Arch zu wechseln, weil mich der Installation und Customization Progress interessiert,
irgendwelche Gedanken dazu, by the way, ich hab gerade ne, äh, 1060 6G, was, ah, Grafikkarte,
und würde mit KVM und Webmanager einen GPU pass-through zu einer Windows VM für Gaming
machen, bräuchte aber noch irgendeine GPU für Linux, irgendwelche Vorschläge, ja,
die, die CPU, äh, die, die Onboard, ein Onboard-GPU für Linux, Frohspit, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön,
Massive Sub, äh, die Onboard-GPU, außer CPU würde ich für Linux verwenden, ähm, allerdings
kann ich mir vorstellen, dass du ganz schnell wieder unter Windows landest, wenn Spielen
das hauptsächlich ist, was du machst, weil der Komfort von einer Spiele-VM mit pass-through
ist jetzt nicht der allerhöchste, zumal du ja eh ne Windows brauchst dafür, achso, du
hast keine Onboard-GPU, tja, noch nen weiterer Grund, Windows zu verwenden, ja, ernsthaft,
das sag ich hier als, als, als Linux-Mann, ja, äh, noch ein weiterer Grund, äh, Windows
zu verwenden, wenn du hauptsächlich spielst, und dich ein bisschen an, an, an, an, an Linux
über ne VM ranzutasten, das ist eh das beste, was ich empfehlen kann, weil dann hast du
nen entsprechendes System unten drunter, was funktioniert, wo du halt auch weißt, es geht,
wenn es nicht, wenn es nicht, wenn es nicht gerade abkackt, was ja bei dir anscheinend
passiert, aber da hast du zumindest von der Theorie ein System drunter, was funktioniert,
wo du alles machen kannst, und, ähm, kannst dich an Linux über ne VM rantasten, wo du
halt jederzeit auch wieder unter Windows kannst, also, ähm, Spiele-VM geht, geht auch ohne
Probleme, aber du musst halt, äh, deine Grafik gerade durchreichen, das bedeutet auch, du
musst, äh, den Monitor an diese Grafikkarte anschließen, also da ist jetzt nix mit, ähm,
den gleichen Monitor ohne Umschalten verwenden zwischen Host und Gaming-VM, also im Prinzip
ist es halt, es sind halt zwei verschiedene Rechner, wenn du ne Gaming-VM hast, mit, äh,
GPU passt du, es sind zwei verschiedene Rechner, du musst auch ne Tastatur und ne Maus durchreichen
wenn du spielen willst, also du hast, du hast quasi zwei verschiedene Rechner da damit,
ähm, das heißt du brauchst auch alles, also komfortabel ist es nicht, nicht wirklich,
deswegen, also was ich, was ich jedem empfehlen kann, der sich ein bisschen an Linux rantasten
will, ist tatsächlich sich VirtualBox oder, äh, auch Forever Workstation zu installieren,
ich hab hier Forever Workstation für mein Linux, ähm, wenn es ein bisschen was kosten
darf, aber man kann auch ohne Probleme kostenlos mit VirtualBox anfangen und sich da ein bisschen
rantasten, das ist die bessere Variante zum, zum Einstieg, Linux Tech Tips hat schon Video
gemacht in VMs zu spielen, war ein Gefrickel, ja klar, ist das auch, da muss man sich aber
unter Linux dran gewöhnen, dass vieles was ein bisschen abseits von ausgetretenen Faden
ist, viel Gefrickel ist, das ist halt unter Linux, nun mal so, da kann man, das kann man
sich auch nicht schönreden, an vielen Stellen muss man Eigeninitiative zeigen und, äh,
ein bisschen, besonders ein bisschen Einsatz bringen, dass die Sachen gut funktionieren.
Ja, aber looking class, also wenn du wirklich spielen willst, würde ich das nicht machen.
Ja, das ist looking class Kupa, was er meint, aber trotzdem, wenn ich irgendwas spielen
würde in der VM, ähm, es gibt kein Problem an looking class, das funktioniert besser
als alle anderen Sachen, du brauchst trotzdem zum Spielen eine, eine ordentliche Tastatur
von Maus, du passt Throot an die VM zum Spielen, ähm, du kannst das machen, aber nicht, dass
du trotzdem, hast du trotzdem auf jeden Fall mehr Input lag als ohne, kann ja gar nicht
anders sein, ich mein, auch wenn du nur ein Frame quasi gebuffert hast, allein schon,
dass dein, dass dein Spiel dann erstmal quasi über den, über den Window Manager von, von
der Verlilungsmost da irgendwie reingerendert wird, ähm, das ist ein bisschen wie Borderless
Window Mode, bloß Betriebssystem übergreifen, das macht ja auch keiner, der, sag mal mal,
Competitive in ein Game spielt, die Leute stellen das ja schon nicht ohne Grund in Fullscreen.
Was, looking class ist GPU, Moment, ja klar, ja klar, das ist, looking class ist doch die
Geschichte, wo du, wo du eine GPU in die, in die VM weiterleitest und dort quasi aus
dem Grafikspeicher mehr oder weniger die Bilder kopierst, auf dein, Linux System, ja, Fensterloses,
der Unterschied ist ganz einfach, Fensterloses Vollbild und normales Vollbild ist der Unterschied,
dass in Borderless Window, der ganze Kram hier von Windows, der ist halt weiter an, also
sprich, wenn man ein Borderless, äh, ein Borderless Window hat, wie beispielsweise
jetzt hier Chrome, Chrome ist jetzt ein Borderless, Borderless Window, wie ein Spiel, so, da kann
ich ohne Probleme ein Overlay drüber machen, auch wenn es gerade unten links ein bisschen
rumspackt, okay, kann ich ohne Probleme, der Sound hat es mir heute echt angetan, kann ich
ohne Probleme ein Overlay drüber machen, in einem Fullscreen-Spiel kann ich das nicht,
weil der ganze Windows, Windows-Manager-Geschichte, Composite-Manager-Geschichte ist da halt nicht
aktiv, das heißt, ich kann auch kein ordentliches Overlay über ein Fullscreen-Spiel machen,
das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert nur sehr rudimentär, ähm, und dann auch nur
auf sehr hacky, hacky Wegen, wenn man nicht gerade Nvidia ist und die Sachen direkt dem
Grafik-Driver machen kann, mit irgendwelchen FPS-Overlays oder so, ähm, das ist ja grad
der Sinn an Fullscreen, deswegen ist das Beste, was man machen kann, bei Spielen, normalerweise,
ähm, für optimale Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit, Fullscreen, nicht Borderless, Fullscreen,
und, ähm, ja am besten noch, äh, Raw-Mouse-Input. Äh, war gestern stehen geblieben, wann kommt
dein Stream-Tool in der aktuellen Version auf Git, falls ich mich mal irgendwie in der
Lage sehe, das mal ordentlich fertig zu machen, sodass man es benutzen kann und nicht nur
ich benutzen kann, und, ähm, wenn ich eine ordentliche, weil das gefällt mir immer noch
nicht, wenn ich eine ordentliche Möglichkeit für Overlays gefunden habe, die nicht so
viel RAM frisst. Also, wahrscheinlich wird das noch eine ganze Weile dauern. Dann dauert
das Raustappen lang, das ist richtig, ja. Fullscreen-Games, wo man raustappt, die, die
brauchen ja aus dem Grund so lang, weil der ganze Windows-Shit wieder geladen werden muss.
Deswegen dauert das Switch zwischen den richtigen Fullscreen-Games und, und, äh, Windows-Desktops
so lang. Ja, so siehts aus. Ähm, mach dein Meme-Tool-Assist-Service, Big-Prain-Idee. Schon
klar, hab ich doch schon am Anfang gesagt, das müsste man echt mal, das ist zwar komplett
sinnlos und würd sich keiner holen, aber warum nicht? Ähm, ach so, äh, Matt, ja, da hast
du recht, also wie gesagt, ne zweite GPU braucht man mit Looking Class. Der Sinn, der Sinn
bei Looking Class ist ja, äh, der Sinn dahinter bei Looking Class ist ja, dass man ne Grafikkarte
in ne VM durchreicht und dann, nur so grob, ich hab mir irgendwann mal durchgelesen, wie
das funktioniert, also ohne Garantie, dass das stimmt, was ich jetzt erzähl, und dass
man dann quasi die, äh, aus dem Grafikspeicher der Grafikkarte, die man in die VM durchgeleitet
hat, da sich das Bild rauskopiert und das ist halt relativ schnell. Also sprich, man
muss keinen Monitor anschließen, sondern kann sich das Bild von der Grafikkarte aus
der VM direkt aus sein Host holen, aber man braucht trotzdem ne zweite GPU. Genau, das
hat's mit Looking Class aufsicht. Eigentlich ne richtig coole Geschichte, ich persönlich
seh nicht so wirklich für mich den Anwendungszweck, weil ich, ich hab mich jetzt halt drauf eingeschossen,
ich verwende halt Windows mit ner Linux VM. Also sprich, ich verwende für alles, wo ich
gerne Linux verwende, Linux, und, äh, für Spiele und Sachen, die halt nur unter Windows
funktionieren, verwende ich Windows. Und da ist die Kombination Windows und darauf ne
Linux VM für mich deutlich einfacher als der umgedrehte Fall.
Was hältst du davon, dass Riot's Vanguard viele Programme blockiert? Wer ist schuld?
Ähm, das ist ja der Anti-Cheat, diese Anti-Cheat-Geschichte von Valorant. Na, dass die Programme blockieren
ist ja gang und gäbe bei Anti-Cheat. Das lustigste war mal bei, war das Black Desert?
Die hatten, die hatten, die haben ja alles geblockt. Da hast du teilweise Programme aufgemacht,
der, was war das, war was total, es war was total Unsinniges, was die geblockt haben.
Ich sag jetzt, es war nicht Paint, aber ich sag jetzt einfach mal, was in der gleichen
Kategorie wie Paint war. Hast du gestartet, ging nicht, solange du Black Desert laufen
lassen hattest, aber witzigerweise, Visual Studio, mit Debugger laufen und allem, das
haben sie nicht geblockt. Das weiß ich auch nicht, das ist nicht, nicht nachzuvollziehen.
Dass so Sachen wie AutoHotKey von einem Anti-Cheat geblockt werden, da kann ich ja noch verstehen.
Das ist gang und gäbe bei Anti-Cheat. Manche schlagen da halt auch über die, über die
Strenge. Stripes007, was willst du denn basteln? Ja, ich hab immer noch CMD. Das Windows Terminal,
wir haben das Windows Terminal doch schon ein paar Mal ausprobiert. Irgendwas hat mich extrem
an dem Windows Terminal gestört. Ich weiß aber jetzt gar nicht mehr was. Irgendwas hat
mich da richtig dran gestört. Ich glaub, dass manche Keyboard Inputs verschluckt wurden
oder so. Hast du eigentlich schon mal Wine plus DXVX, nein, hab ich noch nie. Hab ich
noch nie. Hab ich auch keinen Anwendungszweck für. Weil wie gesagt, ich verwende Windows
für Spiele und Linux für eine, wow, so viele keck Ws. Und für, für, die Vorhaben für
alle Linux Geschichten. Eine gute, Janik, eine gute GPU für dein Linux, wenn du damit
nur 2D Sachen anzeigen willst. Achso, vergiss das. Du hast ja eine AMD-CPU, fuck. Hätte
ich gesagt, nimm die, nimm die, nimm die Intel, nimm die Intel, eingebaute Intel-GPU. Weil
Intel-Grafiktreiber sind unter Linux wirklich nicht schlecht. Irgendeine, irgendeine Low-Budget-Nvidia-Karte
müsste dann deine zweitbeste Wahl sein für Linux. Hey Max, reagierst du auch auf aktuellen
Content? Klar, Reactions sind meine Spezialität. Was? Auf Böhmer Mann Montana Black, oh ne,
die Kombination. Die Kombination, weiß nicht, ob ich mir die geben will. Ich bin, ich finde
die meisten Böhmer Mann Sachen irgendwie Hardcore unlustig. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich
da irgendwie zu Boomer mäßig für bin. Aber die meisten Sachen finde ich nicht witzig.
Ich finde die Sachen auch nicht schlimm, wenn ich sage, oh, sowas kann man nicht machen.
Ich finde die einfach nicht lustig. Anti-Cheat von Valorant blockiert Core-Temp. Okay, das
ist wirklich ziemlich Payne's Champ. Link per PM? Was, sowas? Es ging nicht wegen
meinem indischen Keyboard. Naja, das war ein anderes Problem. Das indische Keyboard habe
ich doch gar nicht hier. Das indische Keyboard habe ich doch, ach doch, ja stimmt, ich hatte
ein indisches Keyboard in der VM mal, weil Windows wieder rumgespackt hat. Das kann
ich mich auch dran erinnern. Wo wir ewig gebraucht haben, bis wir die Tastatur-Settings umstellen
konnten. Anarishos sagt, war nicht das Problem bei Vanguard, dass es irgendwie im Root mitläuft
oder so ähnlich. Ja, das ist das, wo sich die Leute alle wahnsinnig darüber aufgeregt
haben. Dass das weitreichende Rechte hat, ist ja bei Anti-Cheat mittlerweile auch gang
und gäbe. Der Punkt, den ich auch ein bisschen kritisch gesehen habe, ist, dass das Ding
halt die ganze Zeit mitgelaufen ist. Es gibt eigentlich wenig Grund für den Anti-Cheat
die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund mitzulaufen. Wozu? Ich meine, gerade wenn der China-Software
ist, bin ich da skeptisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es heute gelesen habt. Ich war gerade
auf dem Klo und habe dann irgendwie gelesen, ja, Xiaomi-Smartphones spionieren ihre Benutzer
aus. Es wundert mich ja bei nichts mehr mittlerweile. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass mich das
jetzt bei der Facebook-App weniger wundern würde, wie bei irgendeinem Xiaomi-Produkt
oder so. Ich glaube nicht, dass die besser, schlechter sind. Aber gerade bei den Chinasachen
ist halt, ist halt nochmal doppelfragwürdig. Hast du dir schon die neuen JetBrains Academy
net? Was ist das? Learn to program by creating working applications. Start for free. Muss
das sein? Übrigens, ob ihr mir das jetzt glaubt oder nicht, ich habe auf meiner Liste
für Sachen, die wir im Stream machen können, tatsächlich das hier drauf stehen, weil ich
mir gedacht habe, ich flame immer so viel Java, wir könnten ja mal wenigstens, um den
Schein zu wahren, mal ein bisschen Sachen auf der JVM machen, wo ich halt überhaupt
keinen Plan von hab. Okay, und was ist das jetzt? Man lernt, man kann quasi Java lernen
bei denen. Hyperskill. Onboarding. Choose your starting point. Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Aber man muss sagen, die meisten JetBrains Sachen sind eigentlich ganz gut durchdacht.
Würde ich jetzt mal prinzipiell davon ausgehen, dass die Dinge auch ganz gut durchdacht sind
hier. Ich kann euch nicht zeigen, warum Java so schlecht ist, weil Java ist ja an sich
nicht wirklich schlecht. Aber ich flame Java Sachen gerne. Stripes07 schreibt, er will
in jedem Raum einen ESP32 legen mit Temperatursensor. Ja, kann man machen. Hat Nvidia nicht Probleme
mit Linux? Es hat alles irgendwie Probleme mit Linux. Das beste, was funktioniert, sind
tatsächlich Intel-Grafikkarten. Gefolgt von Nvidia, würde ich sagen. Ich habe es aber
schon lange nicht mal native ausprobiert. Linux hat eh, super. Mir geht es ja immer
nur auf den Sack, dass es so ein Riesenakt ist und teilweise eigentlich gar nicht richtig
möglich ist, Hardware-Video-Decoding unter Linux im Browser zum Laufen zu kriegen. So
richtig mit allen Features. Geht ja gar nicht. Was denkst du vom neuen Windows Terminal?
Ich fand es eigentlich ganz cool, aber wie gesagt, irgendwas als wir das ausprobiert
haben, ging mir massiv auf den Keks. Ich weiß aber am besten will nicht mehr was. Ja, genau,
also wie gesagt, das habe ich halt vorhin gleich noch gerade auf dem Klo war, ist mir
das noch ins Auge gesprungen hier. Was ist das? Der Open-Sprinkler, habe ich das richtig
gesehen? Der Open-Sprinkler, Gartenbewässer mit dem Raspberry Pi. Ah, yes, extra nächstes
Projekt schon gesichert. Ich muss mir mal durchlesen, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so wild. Heise
schreibt ja mal, hat ja auch mal ganz gerne Überschriften oder hat immer nur Datenskandal
oder irgendwie oder großes Datenleck und dann guckst du nach und dann ist es dann halt
irgendwie die, welchen Anwälte Button er geklickt hat oder so. Matt, da hast du recht. Das ist
aber wie immer unter Linux, es zieht sich keiner mal den Schuh so richtig an. Die verbringen
mehr Zeit damit, sich untereinander zu flamen, welche der Implementierung jetzt die richtige
ist, dass sie nichts geschissen kriegen. Choose my name, gute Frage. Wann schließt du eigentlich
einen Raspberry Pi an dein Klo an für Statistiken? Was meinst du Choose my name? Oder Chet,
was meinst du? Raspberry Pi oder Controller an Klo anschließen? Was meinst du, habe ich
schon versucht oder nicht? Ich meine ich zeige euch nochmal das Klo. Der Chet, der Chet ist
ich schon sicher, dass ich es schon ausprobiert habe. Chet, ihr legt falsch. Ich habe es noch
nicht probiert und das liegt daran, weil das Ding, ich habe mir aber schon Gedanken gemacht,
das liegt aber daran, weil das Ding keine ordentlichen Schnittstellen hat. Das hat nichts,
wo man was anschließen kann. Also da gibt es auch nichts, wo man großartig was auslesen
könnte. Das Klo ist zu alt, obwohl es neu ist. So, was ich mir überlegt habe ist, man
sieht es hier übrigens ganz schön, hier neben hat man LEDs, man hat hier eine LED am Klo
für Filter, Filter leer oder Fehler und hier eine LED für, oder umgedreht, für Lüftung
ist an und was man machen könnte ist, Fernbedienung IR Sender abfangen, ja das könnte man machen,
allerdings verwende ich die Fernbedienung gar nicht. Die Fernbedienung ist da unten
drinnen, ich verwende zu 99% die Knöpfe nebendran. Das hier ist für Spülung und das hier ist
für, ne, das ist für Spülung, also Bob's Spülung und das hier ist für Wasserstärke.
Da ist ein ComPort dran, ganz ehrlich, da sind, ich hab mir das angeguckt, da sind ein paar
Anschlüsse dran, aber man findet absolut nichts dazu im Internet und es sieht auch nicht
aus wie ein ComPort. So und was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe ist, was man machen könnte,
was man machen könnte, was das bringt, sag mal dahingestellt, was man machen könnte
ist, man könnte hier irgendwo unter die Abdeckung oder irgendwo wo frei ist, könnte man ESP32
Controller stöpseln oder meinetwegen wer es mit einem Raspberry Pi Zero machen will,
kann das auch machen, aber das ist total Overkill und was ich mir überlegt habe ist, man macht
hier unter die Abdeckung einen Controller, man macht hier einen Fotosensor und da einen
Fotosensor, einen Fotoresistor dran, damit kann man erkennen, wenn die LEDs an sind, das
würde ich da einfach draufkleben im Endeffekt. Da quasi so ein Fotoresistor, der erkennt,
wenn Licht an ist, drauf und da ein Fotoresistor drauf und dann würde ich zumindest schon mal
erkennen, wenn das Klo einen Fehler hat oder wenn ich neue Spülflüssigkeit oder so einfüllen
muss und anhand des Lüfters könnte man auch statistisch erfassen, wie oft man auf dem
Klo drauf gesessen hat. Was es einem bringt, mal dahingestellt, möglich ist es. Man könnte
dann auch beispielsweise noch machen, man könnte hier in einem ESP einen Ruttelsensor
machen, dann kannst du beispielsweise auch feststellen, eventuell, müssen wir aber aufbringen,
wer sich drauf gesetzt hat, je nachdem, wie sehr es scheppert. Ja, gibt es ein paar Varianten,
die Sache ist bloß die unterm Strich, was bringt es? Ich habe es ja schon oft gesagt,
ich bin ja ein Fan von, bei Heimautomatisierung, die Sachen zu machen, wo man einen Gewinn
durch hat und da habe ich wenig Gewinn durch. Den einzigen Gewinn, den ich dadurch irgendwie
bekommen würde, ist, dass ich sehe, wie oft ich am Tag auf dem Klo gewesen bin, aber ja,
also warum? Das einzige, was ich mir vielleicht noch vorstellen könnte, ist, dass man dann,
was ich mich manchmal frage ist, wenn ich beispielsweise von der Arbeit heimkomme, also
jetzt gerade eh nicht, weil letztes Jahr Dauer Homeoffice angesagt, und ich zum Beispiel den
Livestream anmachen will, dann frage ich mich manchmal, bevor ich den Livestream anmache,
Max, warst du schon auf dem Klo gewesen? Wenn nicht, gehst du noch mal aufs Klo, bevor du
den Livestream anmachst und dann wäre es ganz gut, wenn ich in meine Heimautomatisierung
nachgucken könnte und feststellen würde, aha, du warst heute schon mal auf dem Klo.
Das ist aber die einzige sinnvolle, ansatzweise sinnvolle Statistik, die ich da aus meinem
Klo gewinnen könnte und wozu, dann, da verschwende ich meine Energie lieber auf andere Sachen
wie Stromzähler klingelsmarter machen und solche Sachen. Ja, so sieht es aus. Ja, eigentlich
wollte man noch ein paar Sachen aufschreiben, aber wir haben noch so viele Sachen zu besprechen
hier. Und dann nur noch eine Nummer integrieren quasi, du meinst glaube ich nicht integrieren,
sondern inkrementieren. Exzellent. Integrieren wäre da ein bisschen was anderes. Levantin,
das ist eine saumäßig gute Idee. Er schreibt, aber dann wäre es nice, wenn du noch einen
OBS-Fork baust, der verhindern könnte, dass man live geht, wenn man noch nicht auf dem
Klo war. Das ist eine ziemlich big brain gute Idee, allerdings würde ich das dann eher
über einen OBS-Plugin lösen. Kann man bestimmt ein Plugin machen. Achso, du meinst, wir bestimmen
das Volumen? Ja, da hast du natürlich recht. Papierbedarf berechnen. Da müsste ich aber
irgendwie noch den Verbrauch mitbekommen. Den kriege ich ja nicht mit. Gewichtssensor
funktioniert hier drinnen nicht. Gewichtssensor funktioniert nicht, weil man sieht es hier
ja in meinem Video, was ich mal gemacht habe. Das, was übrigens mittlerweile 102.000 Aufrufe
bei Klo filme, man hat hier keine Ablage für die Kacke drinnen. Also sprich, das fällt
runter und man kann hier kein Gewichtssensor hin machen. Das werde ich aber auch so nicht
machen, weil es ganz schön Sauerei gibt. Exkriminieren, das müsste man neu erfinden,
das Wort dafür. Vorher, nachher wiegen. Ich habe eine Waage neben dem Klo stehen, da müsste
ja jedes Mal drauf. Naja, okay, das ist weg. Das geht nicht, ja, das stimmt, das kann ich,
das geht nicht. Man kann keine Dateien unter Windows anlegen, die Con heißen. Das ist übelst
fail. Und das Problem habe ich regelmäßig auf der Arbeit, weil irgendein absoluter Big
Brain Entwickler bei uns hat eine Con.Yaml angelegt in unserem Git Repo. Er hat gemeint,
ja, da müssen die ganzen Informationen rein, die man halt so braucht. Con.Yaml. Und jeder,
der jetzt versucht, unter Windows unser Git Repo zu klonen, hat einen Fehler. Also das
geht, das klonen, aber Git sagt dann immer, ja, eine Datei fehlt. Meine Antwort darauf
ist ganz einfach, kein Windows verwenden dafür, dann funktioniert es. Und damit fahren wir
doch erstaunlich gut. Einfach Drucksensoren. Mir sind keine Drucksensoren bekannt, die da
gut funktionieren würden. Die man dafür gut verwenden könnte. Aber im Schnelldurchgang.
Ja, da läuft der Chat, da läuft die Vorschau, da läuft das Memboard für die Bildchen, läuft
auf dem zweiten PC. Also ist schon wichtig. Hatten wir schon? Hatten wir jetzt auch? Hatten
wir jetzt auch? Was sagt AC130? Willst du das unbedingt mal hören heute? Achtung Leute,
das ist ein bisschen verbackt beim Front-Enter. Das zeigt Sachen doppelt an. RGB ans Klo.
Ja, warum nicht? So, also wir machen jetzt noch mal ganz kurz was Sinnvolles. So ausnahmsweise
zwischendurch. Und zwar ein paar Sachen, die ich mir überlegt habe, die man im Stream
machen könnte. Und wie gesagt, falls ihr noch Ideen habt, schreibt es in den Chat, beziehungsweise
schreibt es am besten im Discord in den Vorschläge-Channels. Also ein paar Sachen, was ich mir aufgeschrieben
habe jetzt, was wir machen, was wir machen könnten. Also zeig mal her. Wo habe ich meine
Liste? Also ich wollte mal einen Retropie ausprobieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie monka-tost das Ganze
ist, ob man das im Stream überhaupt machen kann. Aber ich glaube gerade bei den alten
Emulations-Dingern, who cares? Wollte ich mal ausprobieren? Dann wollte ich tatsächlich
mal, aber das werde ich nicht in nächster Zeit machen. Ich schreibe es nochmal auf.
Dann wollte ich mal ein bisschen Java-Kotlin ausprobieren. Einfach nur, weil ich flame
immer so viel über Java, zumindest mal für die Java-Fans, dass ich dann mal einmal im
Stream wenigstens sagen kann, ganz so schlimm ist es ja nicht. Roms werde ich im Stream
nicht runterladen. Ich werde mir die Roms einfach vor dem Stream runterladen. Exzellent.
So, dann wollten wir uns schon lange mal WSL 2 angucken. Das haben wir glaube ich bis
jetzt immer noch nicht gemacht. Dann eine richtig geile Idee, die kam glaube ich vor
zwei Wochen sonntags. Wir wollten mal probieren, ob wir schaffen eine kleine Anwendung, was
auch immer zu programmieren, die rein stack overflow, nein nicht, aber die 9-90% stack
overflow copy-paste ist. Also sprich, ob wir es schaffen eine sinnvolle Anwendung zu programmieren,
die rein aus, oder was heißt rein, ein paar Sachen mussten wir anpassen. Das geht nicht.
Aber eine sinnvolle Anwendung zu programmieren, rein aus Antworten von stack overflow mit
ein bisschen was dazwischen. Was ist der Linux-Bewertung.txt? Das ist die Sachen, die wir uns an, wenn
wir uns neue Linux-Distributionen angucken, so was wir uns immer ungefähr, was wir uns
immer anschauen. Welche Punkte? Ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, dass das funktioniert
mit stack overflow. So, dann wollte ich ja schon die ganze Zeit mal Raspbian XP-Edition
nochmal ausprobieren. Der hat ja letztens Raspbian, um nicht zu verwechseln mit Lesbian,
oder war schlecht. Der war richtig Pains, Pains, Champ, Grinch. Das wollte ich auch
schon mal ausprobieren, weil da ging ja letztens die Capture Card nicht. Da hat irgendeiner
gesagt, ich soll mir mal NixOS angucken, aber da habe ich mal eine Zweifel, dass das
soll nicht interessant ist für ein Stream. Dann wollten wir uns unbedingt mal, und das
wollte ich schon eine Weile machen, mal Flutter angucken, aber am liebsten würde ich das
verschieben, bis Flutter auf dem Desktop zumindest Beta ist und man das da verwenden
kann. Weil Mobile, warum sollte ich hier Mobile-Sachen basteln? Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen,
ja, geht nicht so gut. Kann das sein, dass ich nicht die ganze Liste kopiert habe? Wo
ist denn der Rest? Ja, wir wollten mal ein paar Competitive, ich kann, ich schreibe das
Wort immer falsch, Competitive, genau. Wir wollten mal ein paar Competitive-Programming-Aufgaben
außer Konkurrenz lösen, lösen, außer Konkurrenz, weil wahrscheinlich muss ich das Auto noch
in C++ machen, dann kriege ich wieder Anfälle dabei. Weil wenn ich über eine Sache noch
mehr flame als Java, dann ist es C++. Ich habe gar kein C++-Emote, kann das sein? Leute,
ich habe, ich habe kein C++-Emote. Das Neo-Wim, stimmt, das habe ich mir sogar aufgeschrieben,
das Neo-Wim-Viers-Code-Plugin, das habe ich sogar schon mal ausprobiert, Offstream, und
das erste, was ich ausprobiert habe, hat nicht funktioniert. Die erste Sache, die ich den
Neo-Wim mit Plugins ausprobiert habe, hat nicht, hat gleich nicht funktioniert. Was
ist mit dir? Ja, guter Einwand. So, für dich, wir bauen dich in Visual Studio Code ein.
Capture the Flag habe ich mir auch aufgeschrieben, genau. Eats Capture the Flag-Aufgaben angucken.
Ich bin, ihr wisst ja, ich bin kein geübter Competitive-Programmer und auch kein geübter
Hackermann, der da irgendwelche großartig komplizierten Reverse-Engineering-Geschichten
hinfuddelt, ja. So, also, Beginner. So, dann wollte irgendjemand, dass ich mir ReviOS
angucke. Was ist das überhaupt? Ich hoffe, das hat nichts mit gewissen YouTubern zu tun.
ReviOS. Kennst du Lisp? Ich kenne, ich kenne Dings hier aus. Elisp aus Emacs. Was war denn
noch mal ReviOS? Moment. Eine Google-Seite? What the fuck? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass
Google noch kostenloses Hosting von Seiten hat. Was ist das denn? Ne, ne, ne, ich glaube
nicht, dass es von Google ist. Das ist was, was irgendjemand, der auf Google seine Seiten,
seine Seite hostet. Was ist das? Was, was ist das? Ist ein CSGO-Windows-Image für mehr
FP... Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt debatest du mich, aber Knäherbär, oder? Was, das ist ein CSGO-Windows-Image
für mehr FP... Sowas gibt's? Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken. Das ist so toll.
Nein, nein, das glaube ich ihm nicht. 200 FP, wo sollen die denn herkommen? Das ist die
gleiche Hardware. Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich nicht. Und da steht auch so
wenig dazu. Das ist doch jebait, das ist doch jebait. Change log. Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was es genau ist, aber das wirkt abgedreht genug, dass man das mal ausprobieren muss.
Was Zeug, was es alles gibt? Äh, falsch, falsch, falsch ist die Maul. Was es alles
gibt? Zulull, a massive Zulull. Okay, also, was haben wir noch ein paar Sachen, die wir
machen können? Äh, die Ubuntu 20.4 Beta, die haben wir schon ausprobiert. Die Sache
ist die, mittlerweile ist sie sogar schon raus. Äh, Bedrock Linux? Sollte man noch mal ausprobieren,
da hat auch einer geschrieben. Weiß gar nicht mehr, was das jetzt war. Ich glaube, das ist
das, wo man verschiedene Sachen, äh, von verschiedenen Paketen, man dann schon ein
Paket installieren kann. World's Day Viewer, zwei Monate Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. Excellent
Subscription. Yes, Ibaro, das könnte ich machen, wenn, wenn Vodafone wieder rumspackt und ich
eine gute Idee hab, wie ich das hinkriege, dass ich da nur mal in Streaming Traffic drüber,
drüber rote. Die komplette Home-Automatisierung mal im Stream durchgehen, das geht nicht,
da ist zu viel Leak am Start. Da müsste ich zu sehr aufpassen. Irgendjemand hat gesagt,
ich soll mal ein PXE-Server aufsetzen. Keine Ahnung, ob ich das in der heutigen Zeit noch
machen sollte. Sorin OS hatten wir schon. Sorin OS hatten wir schon und ich glaube mich
erinnern zu können, dass mir Sorin OS nicht sonderlich gut gefallen hat. Es könnte aber
auch eines der guten Sachen gewesen sein. Warte mal, welche Linux Sachen haben wir gefallen,
die wir ausprobiert haben im Stream? Das China Linux hat mir gefallen, unter der Auflage
jetzt ist es China Linux. Elementary hat mir ganz gut gefallen und Sedux oder wie das
hieß, Sedux oder so, fand ich noch ganz okay. Power Mode, das habe ich schon mal irgendwo
gesehen. Ansonsten haben mir die alle nicht sonderlich gut gefallen. Also nichts hat mir
besser gefallen als mein Manjaro mit i3-WM. Popo OS haben wir auch ausprobiert und haben
mir auch nicht gefallen. Anime Girls with Programming Books, das haben wir uns schon
angeguckt. Eine Sache habe ich gedacht, können wir ein Programmiertechnisch machen? Wir könnten
so einen Fake Google Earth mal machen mit OpenStreetMaps, weil wie gesagt, das verwende ich ja gerade
für das eine Projekt, was ich mit meinem Arbeitskollege zusammen mache und da gibt es mal ganz coole
Sachen, die man zeigen kann. Wie weit ist dein Kartenmonteur Tool? Es hat sich seit einem
Monat nichts mehr getan, weil mein Mitstreiter oder der, der eigentlich die Idee hatte, nicht
mit neuen Informationen beikommt und ich werde jetzt auch erstmal nicht weitermachen, bis
es da nicht neue Infos dazu gibt. Ich kann ja nicht ins Blaue reinprogrammieren, ohne
irgendwas zu wissen. Genau, dann wollte ich mal, weil es geht, mal Android auf dem, auf
dem Raspberry Pi 4 ausprobieren. Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn. Abonniert Twitch Prime. Huge
Prime Sub. Danke schön für den Sub. Einfach, weil es geht. Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn,
meiner Ansicht nach, Android auf dem Raspberry zu installieren. Aber ich würde mal gucken,
ob es geht. Solos. Haben wir Solos schon probiert? Ey, wir haben so viele Sachen schon durchprobiert.
Ich kann mich da gar nicht mal an alles erinnern. Glaube, du hast das übersehen. Wenn nicht,
sorry. Nee, habe ich. Habe ich wirklich übersehen. Easy. Rick and Morty Themed. Das ist auch
so ein Trend, der voll an mir vorbeigegangen ist. Wie wäre es mal mit dem Rechenzentrums
Video euer? Der Felix hat mich letztens auch schon wieder gefragt, wollen wir das Rechenzentrums
Video hochladen? Aufgenommen haben wir es ja. Ich speichere mir den Link mal. Ja, ne. Gucken,
ob es vielleicht doch was ist. Serenity OS. Was ist denn Serenity OS? Serenity OS. Ach
ja, dieses Dings Reaktor erst wollte ich ausprobieren. Dieser dieser einfach meiner vor allem dieses
Windows Nachbau. Ich habe ihn noch nie ausprobiert. Ich wollte ihn einfach mal installieren und
mir angucken. Serenity OS. Was ist das? Ach, ist das das Ein-Mann-Betriebssystem? Ist das
dieses Ein-Mann-Betriebssystem? Ja, das das können wir uns echt mal angucken. Ich meine,
da gibt es nichts großartig zu gucken, wahrscheinlich außer zu stauen, was man alleine alles hinkriegt.
Irgendwann wollen wir uns nochmal Windows 10x angucken, habe ich aber kein richtiges Gerät
für. Was ich schon lange mal gesagt habe, was wir machen wollen, ist einen Mikrotik-Router
einrichten mit VLANs und Zeug, was man so machen kann. GraphQL schon benutzt, ja. Ach
ja, stimmt. GraphQL wollte ich mir auch noch mal zusammen mit euch im Stream angucken, weil
das verwenden wir für unsere Routenplan-Anwendung, um die es eben gerade vorher schon mal kurz
ging. Da ist das Backend auch sehr leichtgewichtig mit einem GraphQL davor, wo man alles abfragt
und vieles im Frontend macht. Aber in der Tiefe verwenden wir GraphQL da noch gar nicht
und ich wollte mir im Stream mal eine Runde GraphQL angucken, wie das da mit Filter und
Versuch und sonst was aussieht. Das ist glaube ich gar nicht verkehrt. Hast du dir schon mal
die Sophos XG Fireboard angeschaut? Ja, vor 5 Jahren oder so, weil ich glaube, das Ding
ist schon relativ alt. Ich bin damit nicht warm geworden. Der Dönerbruder fragt, hast
du oder irgendjemand aus dem Chat einen Vorschlag für eine Hausaufgabe, ne, für eine Hausarbeit
im Bereich Python? Wir sollen für die Uni einen Vortrag ausarbeiten, der über 15 Seiten
geht, aber leider habe ich noch nicht so viel Ahnung von Python. Eine sinnvolle Anwendung
kannst du dir ja überlegen, ohne dass du Ahnung von der Programmiersprache hast. In welche
Richtung soll es denn gehen? Vielleicht fällt uns irgendwas ein Schönes jetzt. Streaming
Setup, das ist eigentlich ziemlich banal mein Streaming Setup. Zwei Rechner, Shader, Maus
und Tastatur und OBS. DMZ, ja. In welche Richtung soll die Anwendung noch gehen? Egal
was. Boah, das ist so Wildcard. Mach irgendeine Machine Learning Geschichte, das ist zur Zeit
voll angesagt. Und da ist Python geradezu prädestiniert für irgendwelche Machine Learning Geschichten.
Mach irgendeine einfache Machine Learning Geschichte. Einfach in Anführungszeichen.
Aber irgendwas in der Richtung, das bietet sich mit Python an, dank TensorFlow und Konsorten.
Du kannst zum Beispiel ein bisschen Textanalyse machen oder, ja, keine Ahnung. Was ich auch
noch mal, genau was stimmt, was ich auch noch mal testen wollte ist, ob man XFCE zum Laufen
kriegt unter WSL2. Captain Peng schreibt, muss gerade Multithreading in C in der Uni
sein, ist echt super. Oder ist echt kacke, ja. Also Multithreading ist eh so eine Sache
für sich und in C, diese Loadlevel-P-Threads-Geschichte ist nicht ohne. Das Schöne an C aber ist,
das muss man im Vergleich zu anderen Programmierspielen auch mal sagen, in C ist in der Regel immer
relativ gut nachvollziehbar, ist in anderen Sprachen auch. Es ist immer relativ gut nachvollziehbar
in C. Was passiert? Da ist halt keine Magic am Start, wo man sich wundern muss, hey, warum
ist es passiert an der Stelle, warum ruckelt es jetzt alle 5 Sekunden mal und irgendwann
kommt man darauf, ah, weil der Garbage-Collector läuft oder so. Das hast du in C alles nicht.
Also in C ist immer relativ gut nachvollziehbar, solange es halt noch halbwegs übersichtlich
ist, was wann passiert. Und das ist für Multithreading eine wichtige Geschichte, weil die meisten
Probleme mit Multithreading kommt ja nicht durch Multithreading an sich, sondern dass
man selbst zu blöd ist, richtig zu Multithreading. Ja, C Sharp ist für Multithreading gut. Zumindest
das Handling finde ich da auch sehr angenehm. Ablässt einen über Programmiersprachen,
das mache ich doch eh immer zwischendrin. Den Telekom-Karriere-Matcher, den haben wir
schon gemacht. Ach ja, das wollte ich unbedingt mal ausprobieren. Das Nano-Framework, das
ist eine.NET-Implementierung für Microcontroller und.NET Meadow heißt das Ding, das ist ein
Microcontroller, der explizit dafür gemacht ist, mit.NET Core programmiert zu werden.
Wollte ich einmal ausprobieren. Ach ja, übrigens der Kabum, gestern Abend, wir hatten es ja
doch ein bisschen von Games und er hat mir erzählt, was so eine Sache, die er gerade
spielt und er spielt irgendwie so eine komische Jagd-Simulation, so mit auf dem Hochstand
sitzen und sowas. Kennt das einer von euch? Irgendwie sowas hier Call of the Wild oder
so? Steam? The Hunter, genau, das spielt er. Das spielt er und also ich habe auch erst
mal gesagt, alle im Leben nicht, im Leben würde ich das nicht spielen. Und er hat gemeint,
doch hier voll entspannend und nice Game. Ja, also man sieht auch für solche Games gibt
es durchaus Abnehmer, ja. Diahunter, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Hannah Montana
Linux, ach das ist dumm, dumm Zeug. Dass es irgendeiner den dämlichen Hintergrund gemacht
hat und das alles lila, dass sie schwach sind. Das braucht kein Mensch. Was hältst du von
funktionaler Programmierung unabhängig von der Sprache? Ich finde das ist ein sehr interessantes
Themengebiet. Kenne ich mich leider nicht wirklich gut damit aus. Das einzige, was ich
gemacht habe ist ein paar F-Sharp Tutorials, aber es ist auch schon eine ganze Weile her,
mittlerweile ist es bestimmt viel einfacher und besser geworden. Und es braucht schon
echt extra Gehirnwindungen, bis man da durchsteigt. Aber der Sebaro kennt sich damit gut aus,
der muss gerade Haskell machen in der Uni, habe ich gehört. Archelux mit E3 sehe ich
ganz genauso, beste. Aber das müssen wir nicht ja eh drauf schreiben, weil das haben
wir ja schon gemacht. Temple OS, ey so ein Schwachsinn da. Kannst du dir mal den OWASP
Juice, oh das hört sich an, das hört sich an wie irgendwas unanständiges. Der Saftshop,
der Saftladen quasi. Das hört sich unanständig an. Ach nee Moment, ist das dieser Shop,
der nur dafür gemacht ist um Sicherheitslücken zu finden? Das habe ich schon mal gesehen
das Ding. Achja irgendwann müssen wir übrigens auch mal by the way noch die Titanfall Kampagne
fertig spielen und ich wollte auch noch die MW2 Remastered mal spielen. Zwischenrennen,
wir können auch mal wieder mal irgendwann mal zur Abwechslung spielen. Haben wir sonst
hier noch irgendwas drinne stehen? Black Mesa haben wir doch schon, nee Black Mesa fertig
spielen will ich nicht. Also der Bosskampf am Ende war ganz gut aber das eine Level
in dem wir aufgehört haben das ist so dermaßen kacke da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr. Das will
ich nicht nochmal spielen. Wireguard haben wir schon ausprobiert. Wir wollten uns irgendwann
mal nochmal meine aktuelle Rust Version angucken. Spielst du Valorant? Nee. Ich gucke aber echt
gerne Valorant Streams. Ich kenne mich wahrscheinlich von allen Leuten die nicht Valorant spielen
und sich auch noch nicht um einen Key bemüht haben am besten aus mit dem Game, weil ich
so viele Streams schon geguckt habe. Im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Zuschauern die gerade bei
Overwatch Channels immer rumspammen so nach dem Motto Resident, Sleeper, Valorant, Overwatch,
finde ich die Valorant Streams echt spannend. Fileserver aufsetzen das ist fast schon ein
bisschen haben wir bestimmt schon mal gemacht und es ist wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen
zu kurzfristig für den Stream, weil man so ein Fileserver installieren das dauert eine
halbe Stunde. Gut bei mir dauert das drei Stunden weil ich wieder die Hälfte nichts
davon mache. So was habe ich denn so aufgeschrieben? Wireguard haben wir schon ausprobiert. Ah
ja was ich unbedingt noch ausprobieren wollte meine Vita Flaschen. Ich habe doch zu
Release weil ich so dämlich war eine Playstation Vita gekauft. Und für die soll es ja wohl
mittlerweile recht lustige und gute Custom Firmware geben. IOS, da kann ich nicht, da
habe ich keinen Schimmer von. Ich glaube das war's. Ich glaube das war's Leute.
Mehr? Ich scroll hier gerade noch mal durch, aber mehr habe ich glaube ich an Ideen. Es
ist ja nicht so dass es wenig mehr aber mehr habe ich anscheinend hier nicht mehr drinne
stehen. Die Vita war von Anfang an irgendwie tot. Ich weiß auch nicht was Sony sich da
wieder überlegt hat. So das ist halt zusätzlich zu den Sachen die wir halt auch sonst noch
eh immer wieder machen. Den Hurt hört wie auch immer man das ausspricht. Ne, wozu?
Hey Max du benutzt einen Mikrotik, ich speichere mir das gerade noch mal. Stream Ideen. Du
benutzt doch einen Mikrotik Router welchen hast du genau? Ich glaube Hex PoE heißt das
Ding. Also nix teures. Hex PoE. Den da genau. Wunderbar. Top Gerät. Sau schnelles Routing.
Was man halt bei so einem Internet Anschluss wie wir hier haben nicht braucht aber ich
habe halt auch viele andere Sachen dranne. Mehrere Netzwerke, zwei verschiedene, drei
verschiedene WLANs, unterschiedliche WLANs, da wird ein bisschen was geroutet. Ja. Und
das Ding kostet glaube ich 60 Euro oder so. Ja das ist die Lite Variante, die andere ist
ein bisschen teurer aber den kann ich echt empfehlen, der ist gut. P2P WLAN, was ist denn
PTP WLAN? Ist das irgendeine Mesh Geschichte oder so? Ich glaube da kann ich nicht allz viel
zu sagen. Passive Exile meinst du? Haben wir ja nie so wirklich gemacht. Ich habe einen
Passive Exile Stream gemacht, den wir abgebrochen haben weil ein Voder vorne rum gespackt hat.
Ja habe ich mitgekriegt, dass Passive Exile für die Switch kommen soll. Smug Switch?
Nein kann er wahrscheinlich nicht. Auf die Idee bin ich noch nicht gekommen, dass das
für mich daheim relevant sein könnte. Donpits ja warum? Außer dass der Kram wahrscheinlich
viel Strom frisst und laut ist. Ach Richtfunk WLAN. Ach ja Cobol. Cobol wollten wir doch
vorhaben. Sag mal habe ich das vergessen reinzuschreiben? Klar Cobol Stream wollten wir doch mal machen.
Keck weh. Kent eigentlich wäre einen guten Weg sich als Noob mit BGP und so vertraut zu
machen. Also gerade mit BGP fällt mir da nichts gescheites ein. Ich habe mit allen anderen
Routing-Protokollen das USB-F oder so kannst du daheim ausprobieren. Aber gerade mit BGP...
Multivaneinricht mit Failover kannst mit Vodafone-Test ohne Stecker ziehen zu müssen. Ja weil das
relativ aufwendig ist und ich müsste mir erstmal gucken wie man das am besten macht. Auf jeden
Fall mit einem Endpunkt im Internet. Also man braucht auf jeden Fall auf der Gegenseite auch
was dass das ordentlich funktioniert. Was ist das? Ah das kenne ich nicht Sebaro. Poggers. Ja der
Chat. Chat ist wieder huge brain. Was weil der Mikro Tick die MTU von 1492 nicht halten kann und
IPv6 auch Probleme. Warum sollte der Mikro Tick in irgendeiner Art und Weise Probleme haben mit
der MTU von so einer Standard. Das ist ja so nur nach 15 MTU. Das wird mich jetzt echt
wundern. Dass du da keine Jumbo Frames rüber machen kannst oder so leuchtet mir ein. Ja soweit
so gut. Morgen Homeoffice angesagt. Ich muss ja mal wieder sagen wie angenehm das ist mit
Homeoffice. Einfach ausschlafen so halbwegs zumindest und sich dann an Rechner setzen und
direkt auf der Arbeit sein ist schon äußerst nice und vor allem direkt wieder daheim sein
von der Arbeit ist auch sehr nice. Ich gucke gerade ob es irgendwas gibt was ich hosten kann was
views bräuchte. Nee irgendwie nicht. Arbeit ist doch eh nur vier Tage die Woche das ist
korrekt. Und weiter. Deswegen werden die Vorteile doch nicht weniger. Keine deutsche Bahn das ist
richtig. Das ist tatsächlich Erholung pur dass ich nicht Bahn fahren muss. Wie sieht dein
Arbeitsalltag im Homeoffice eigentlich aus? Okay das kann ich mal versuchen so ungefähr grob zu
beschreiben. Also ich fang meist so 7.30 Uhr oder so an. Also ich wach auf so 7.15 Uhr oder so.
Wie gesagt normalerweise muss ich ja 5.45 Uhr aufstehen also ist schon ist schon echt ein riesen
Unterschied. Ich stehe so 7.15 Uhr auf dann kriege ich die Katze erstmal was zu futtern weil die
sonst übelst rum nervt. Dann mache ich schon mal einen Rechner an vielleicht mache ich auch
schon einen Browser auf und lock mich mal ein oder so. Meistens gegen 7.30 Uhr oder 7.45 Uhr
oder so in dem Dreh fange ich an. Da schicke ich eine Mail rum so nach dem Motto bin jetzt da. Dann
gucke ich auch dass auf den beiden Smartphones Teams an ist und im Browser Teams läuft dass
ich erreichbar bin. Dann gucke ich erstmal ob es irgendwelche E-Mails gegeben hat oder irgendwelche
Tickets Updates gegeben hat die ich vielleicht noch nicht mitgekriegt habe. Ist immer gerade im
Homeoffice denke ich ganz relativ wichtig dass man noch halbwegs auf dem aktuellen Stand ist.
Und dass man es ist im Homeoffice schwieriger auf dem aktuellen Stand zu bleiben wie wenn man
da auf der Arbeit unterwegs ist weil da kriegt man mehr links und rechts mit dem Homeoffice ist
das halt nicht so. Da gucke ich immer wie gesagt ein bisschen die Mails durch, gucke mir mal ein paar
Tickets an ob es da neue Updates gibt. Dann dauert es auch nicht lang bis sich schon irgendeiner über
Teams meldet und irgendwas will. Letztens wieder wahnsinnige Big Brain Nachricht bekommen am Tag
wo ich nicht auf der Arbeit war. Ich suche es euch raus. Massive Brain Message hier. Also ich
dachte das ist ein Message die ich in Teams gekriegt habe. An dem Tag wo ich nicht da bin.
So nach dem Motto Merch Request xy. Könntest du diese Änderung mit der nötigen Eile bearbeiten
schrägstrich ausrollen. Da habe ich ihm geschrieben ja ich bin heute nicht da wofür ist das denn und
ist das dringend und als Antwort kommt ja. Lekt's? Nö geht. Musste kecken ja ich wusste auch kecken
wenn ich das sehe. Also das ist schon wirklich so und so Nachrichten hast du halt öfter ja. Gerade
nachdem ich halt an der Position bin. Das ist halt voll der Zoomer nein. Das ist genau das Gegenteil.
Der Kerl ist garantiert kein Zoomer. Das ist eher das Gegenteil. Ja wie gesagt weil ich ja gerade an
dieser Position bin. Dass ich mittlerweile mehr Sachen review von anderen Leuten was die
programmiert haben als dass ich selbst was programmiere. Kommen so Dinge öfters. Irgendwas
in der Richtung hat sich dann meistens nachdem ich immer Tickets geguckt habe Mails geguckt
habe schon irgendeiner per Teams gemeldet oder aber zu Zeiten geschrieben wo ich nicht online
war. Da muss ich die Teamsmäßig noch nachgucken. Das können die unterschiedlichen Sachen. Also der
häufigste Fall ist tatsächlich sowas hier. Dass die Leute irgendwas angeblich ganz furchtbar
dringendes haben was jetzt sofort gehotzfixed werden muss. Und wenn du da mal nachfragst so
nach dem Motto ja hast du das schon mal mal angefragt und geklärt ob das jetzt überhaupt ob das
inwieweit das passt und ob die Leute die Bescheid wissen müssen schon Bescheid wissen so nö nö nö
hab ich das machst du. So ist das nicht gedacht. Ja also was ist meistens relativ relativ oft.
Was auch erschreckend und ohne scheißleute erschreckend oft vorkommt sind Leute die mich
anschreiben und sagen Max ich habe in meinem Kitbranche was gelöscht oder ich hab meinen
ich hab meinen Kitbranche irgendwie kaputt gemacht. Man würde eigentlich davon ausgehen
dass gerade Entwickler 2020 in der Lage sind Kit halbwegs zu bedienen. Also wohlgemerkt eines der
mit Abstand am meisten meisten verbreiteten wie hast du Software Tools überhaupt. Und gerade
einen Entwickler würde ich von ausgehen. Der bekommt es ganz gut hin. Aber das ist nicht so.
Ich krieg so viele Nachrichten dass irgendwelche Git-Geschichten angeblich nicht gehen würden
oder irgendwas weg ist oder etwas nicht mehr findet oder Dinge die meistens die meistens ich gucke
da drauf ich kann den schon meistens anhand der Fehlerbeschreibung sagen okay hast du das und
das vorher gemacht. Ach nee habe ich vergessen. Das weiß ich sofort. So nach dem Motto Max ich
habe eine Merch Request aufgemacht. Es hat jetzt zig Konflikte und mag nicht und geht nicht. Ja
hast du mal dein Master gepullt und mal versucht zu rebasen vorher. Ich meine der Branche ist drei
Monate alt. Klar ist da irgendwas passiert in der Zwischenzeit. Achso nee habe ich vergessen. Ja
dann mach mal. Das kommt öfters. Das ist quasi schon immer direkt morgens am Start. Was auch
ganz gern kommt ist wenn dann irgendwie einer dieser super nötigen fixes irgendwas kaputt
gemacht hat was bei uns relativ oft vorkommt meistens ist es nichts wirklich bahnbrechend also
nichts wirklich super Schlimmes aber dann gehen manchmal irgendwelche Sachen nicht oder Sachen
verhalten sich komisch dass ich dann die Meldung kriege so nach dem Motto hier gestern seit ich
mir den Fix eingespielt habe geht irgendwas nicht und dann muss ich den Reverse Lookup machen an
der Stelle und sagen okay an welcher Stelle geht was nicht und dann gucke ich mir die Fixes durch
das okay das war anscheinend der hier da sage ich sage ich dem okay geh doch gleich zum Entwickler
der kann am besten erklären was er gemacht hat. So was kommt auch öfters. Ist es entspannter zu
reviewen fragt der Gary von Bowen. Ja entspannter schon spaßiger ist es aber selbst Sachen zu programmieren. Entspannter ist es
entspannter ist es weil man ist selbst nicht in der Position dass man irgendwas funktionieren
das abliefern müsste und kann eigentlich beliebige Sachen anmeckern die einem nicht gefallen also
ja also entspannter ist es zu reviewen ja. Wir brauchen das Meme Board für Teams. Oh ja das wäre
was ich hätte Leute ich hätte so gern bei uns im Teams eine Runde keqw und vor allem halt mit den
Sounds dabei. Am besten ist wenn ein Merch Request aufgeht kommt erstmal eine Runde. Das muss man
erstmal einbauen ja. Ja PC lustig das ist bei den meisten Sachen so es ist immer dringend muss
sofort erledigt werden. Allerdings wollen sich die Leute dann meistens nicht um die Sachen kümmern
die erforderlich sind dass es komplett erledigt werden kann. Ja Captain Peng sagt ich fordere zu
viel. Ich weiß dass du das natürlich nicht ernst meinst aber das denken sich wirklich einige.
Ich weiß es ist 2020 meine Güte. Habe ich auf den Twitch Status auf. Ja es stimmt es stimmt
dass wenige wirklich gut GIT bedienen können. Gerade man muss auch sagen also die GIT Kommando
Zeile hat schon so ein paar Tücken ich meine zum Beispiel wann schreibst du Origin Slash
Branch Name Origin Doppelpunkt Branch Name korrekterweise müsste man ja sagen Remote Leerzeichen
Branch Name Remote Doppelpunkt Branch Name Remote Slash Branch Name und sowas. Es hat eine gewisse
Logik aber die erschließt sich eigentlich auf den ersten Blick. Richtig gut bedienen können es
wenige aber so um sag mal um einen normalen Merch Request bzw. Pull Request aufzumachen da
brauchst du ja nicht viel. Du musst ab und zu mal in Master Branch pullen du musst deinen eigenen
Branch auf dem aktuellen Stand halten und ab und zu mal vielleicht was resetten aber das war's.
Choose my name du kannst bei GIT ausnahmslos alles rückgängig machen sogar Sachen die du
nicht committed hast solang du es bei dir einmal GIT geändert hast also du kriegst du verlierst in
GIT so gut wie nie irgendwas. Levantin ja das ist eine Sache da könnte ich mich auch das ist
richtig Low-Brain 3-Head das ist richtig das ist richtig bescheuert. Er schreibt hier nämlich
GIT ist echt schlimm 99% nutzen irgendeine Rotz GUI und checken da nicht was passiert korrekt.
GIT bedient sich tatsächlich über die Kommandozeile am besten. Das einzige in GIT wo ich bei
komplexeren Sachen empfehlen würde eine GUI zu verwenden ist bei Merch Konflikten wenn man
wirklich mal einen großen langen Merch Konflikt hat was nicht so oft vorkommt dann kann man
irgendwelche DIV-Tools verwenden braucht man nicht unbedingt aber das ganz nützlich ansonsten
braucht man das nicht. Und GIT GUIs ist das schlimmste. Wisst ihr wie das das Eclipse GIT
Plugin heißt? Nennt sich IGIT. Äh ernsthaft. Kein Witz eigentlich überhaupt nicht sondern
sondern wirklich ernst gemeint Champ.